This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 1930s, an unlikely man from rural Louisiana rose to political stardom. Huey Long appealed to working-class Americans with fiery speeches and a populist agenda. He promised free textbooks, better infrastructure, and redistribution of wealth. While we might have millionaires, and men worth two million, and men worth three million, maybe, and men worth maybe five, or six million, but that nonetheless I must be a limit on how big any one man could get. Thousands gathered to hear him speak. His promise to make every man a king soon earned him a nickname,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。20世纪30年代，一位来自路易斯安那州农村的非典型人物登上了政治舞台。休伊·朗以激昂的演讲和民粹主义议程吸引了美国工人阶级。他承诺提供免费教科书、改善基础设施并重新分配财富。虽然我们可能有百万富翁，有身家两百万、三百万，甚至五六百万的人，但无论如何，一个人能拥有的财富必须有一个上限。成千上万的人聚集在一起听他演讲。他承诺让每个人都成为国王，这很快为他赢得了绰号，
the kingfish. But Huey Long also made powerful enemies along the way. Critics saw him as a dangerous demagogue. They warned that he was crooked, cunning, and completely unconcerned with checks and balances. He fired those who opposed him, took over state agencies, and appointed loyalists. When Louisiana State University published a newspaper article criticizing him, Hughie Long saw to it that the seven students who wrote the piece were expelled. Hughie Long wasn't just popular. He was magnetic, dangerous to some, divine to others. He rewrote the rules and dared the system to stop him.
“国王鱼”。但休伊·朗在这一过程中也树立了强大的敌人。批评者视他为危险的煽动者。他们警告说他狡诈、阴险，且完全无视制衡机制。他解雇反对者，接管州政府机构，并任命亲信。当路易斯安那州立大学发表文章批评他时，休伊·朗设法让撰写该文章的七名学生被开除。休伊·朗不仅受欢迎，他极具魅力，对一些人来说是危险的，对另一些人来说则是神圣的。他改写了规则，并挑战体制，看谁能阻止他。
In 1929, after he became governor of Louisiana, Hughie Long was impeached on charges of bribery, corruption, and abuse of power. Rather than prove his innocence, he orchestrated a political blockade in the state senate. He persuaded senators to sign a letter vowing not to convict him, which made a trial pointless. He went on to become a U.S. senator. His popularity didn't just survive. It soared. Today on the show, we take a deep dive into the psychological forces that draw us to charismatic figures
1929年，在担任路易斯安那州州长后，休伊·朗因贿赂、腐败和滥用职权受到弹劾。他没有证明自己的清白，而是在州参议院策划了一场政治封锁。他劝说参议员签署一份承诺不给他定罪的信，这使得审判变得毫无意义。他后来成为了美国参议员。他的受欢迎程度不仅没有受损，反而飙升。今天在节目中，我们将深入探讨那些吸引我们追随魅力型人物的心理力量，
in the worlds of politics, sports, and religion. The science of loyalty and the building blocks of devotion this week on Hidden Brain. We often turn to history to understand how the world changes. We examine the lives of leaders who sparked revolutions and gathered thousands behind their cause. We ask, what made these leaders so powerful? What explained their influence?
无论是在政治、体育还是宗教领域。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨忠诚的科学和奉献的基石。我们经常求助于历史来理解世界是如何变化的。我们审视那些引发革命并聚集了成千上万追随者的领导人的生活。我们不禁要问，是什么让这些领导人如此强大？是什么解释了他们的影响力？
How did they manage to change the course of history? At the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill, historian Molly Worthen explores how individuals inspire change, create movements, and sometimes change the world. Molly Worthen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Molly, I want to talk about some unlikely leaders in American history. Let's start in the 18th century. Jamima Wilkinson was born in Rhode Island in 1752. When she was 23, she felt.
他们是如何设法改变历史进程的？在北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校，历史学家莫莉·沃森探索了个人如何激发变革、创造运动，有时甚至改变世界。莫莉·沃森，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。莫莉，我想谈谈美国历史上一些非典型的领导人。让我们从18世纪开始。杰迈玛·威尔金森于1752年出生在罗德岛。23岁时，她感到，
ill and was on the brink of death, when she recovered, she claimed to have undergone a profound spiritual transformation. What did she say happen to her? She reported that she had seen two angels, and they had delivered this amazing message to her. They told her that her body was a vessel for the Holy Spirit, that in fact, Jemima Wilkinson, the 23-year-old human female, had died, and now her body was a vessel for this androgynous divine presence. She stopped dressing like a conventional woman of her time. She stopped using female pronouns whenever she could, wore her hair long and wore a large gray felt hat, began dressing in a smock that concealed her figure, looked a bit like a dressing
病入膏肓，濒临死亡。康复后，她声称自己经历了一场深刻的精神蜕变。她说发生了什么？她报告说她看到了两位天使，他们向她传达了一个惊人的信息。他们告诉她，她的身体是圣灵的容器，事实上，23岁的人类女性杰迈玛·威尔金森已经死了，现在她的身体是这个雌雄同体的神圣存在的容器。她不再像当时传统的女性那样穿着打扮。她尽可能停止使用女性代词，留长发，戴一顶灰色大毡帽，开始穿一件遮住身材的罩衫，看起来有点像晨衣，
gown, sometimes wore a purple cravat, and she launched a preaching campaign. Her message in the context of the revolution, right, this is 1776, that she has this attack and is reborn as the public universal friend, is a kind of vague one that is compatible with a lot of different theological questions and doubts about existing churches. questions about the end times, that a whole range of followers were having in this era. And she begins speaking to all kinds of crowds of people who are out of sync, I guess you could say, in some way or another, with the prevailing rhythms of society. So she goes to funerals.
有时戴着紫色领结，并开展了一场传教运动。在革命的背景下，也就是1776年，她声称自己经历了一场攻击并重生为“公共普遍之友”，这种信息比较模糊，与当时人们对现有教会的许多神学问题和疑虑相兼容。关于末世的问题，在那个时代，许多追随者都有这些疑问。于是，她开始向各种各样的人群演讲，这些人以某种方式与当时社会的主流节奏不合拍。所以她去参加葬礼，
She speaks to prisoners. She also addresses kind of open-air markets, if a sympathetic minimum. will give her his pulpit. She takes advantage of that. And some wander in to hear this unusual person who they can't quite place. Maybe they can't quite figure out if this is a man or a woman. They can't quite make out the actual import of the kind of vague theological pronouncements. Some find it ridiculous. They see this as a young woman who's kind of put on a costume. But a surprising number, I mean, eventually a few hundred. people are compelled by the public universal friends' invitation to step out of whatever
她对囚犯讲话。如果有人愿意提供讲坛，她也会在露天市场演讲。她利用了这一点。有些人走进来听这个他们无法归类的不寻常的人。也许他们无法确定这是一个男人还是一个女人。他们无法完全理解那些模糊的神学声明的实际含义。有些人觉得这很荒谬。他们认为这是一个穿上戏服的年轻女子。但令人惊讶的是，最终有几百人被“公共普遍之友”的邀请所打动，走出你所处的，
role you've been handed by your place in revolutionary American society and find something new. And so we're talking about followers who range from young women who perhaps had not quite landed in a family arrangement that was acceptable in society to very established kind of senior men in the community. One of her most prominent followers is a Rhode Island colonial judge named William Potter, who puts a lot of his personal fortune to the service of her growing ministry. By the 1790s, she is leading a crew of about 400 followers
革命时期美国社会赋予你的角色，去寻找新的东西。所以我们谈论的追随者范围很广，从那些在社会可接受的家庭安排中找不到位置的年轻女性，到社区中非常有地位的资深男性。她最著名的追随者之一是罗德岛殖民地法官威廉·波特，他将自己的大量个人财富投入到她日益壮大的事工中。到了18世纪90年代，她带领着大约400名追随者，
to found a utopian community that she calls New Jerusalem in upstate New York, to fully break from the rhythm of life in ordinary communities in revolutionary era, America. I want to jump forward to the 19th century. Marcus Garvey was born in 1887 in Jamaica. He spent his teenage years working as a printer's apprentice and eventually joined a nationalist club that promoted Jamaican independence. He spent some time in Europe working as a journalist and then founded the Universal Negro Improvement Association and moved to New York. I understand that he was an unlikely
在纽约州北部建立了一个她称之为“新耶路撒冷”的乌托邦社区，以彻底打破革命时代普通社区的生活节奏。我想跳到19世纪。马库斯·加维于1887年出生在牙买加。他十几岁时做印刷学徒，后来加入了一个促进牙买加独立的民族主义俱乐部。他在欧洲做过一段时间记者，然后创立了“世界黑人进步协会”并搬到了纽约。据我了解，他是一个非典型的，
leader, Molly, not a great speaker and with lots of critics. Absolutely. The type of African-American leader that the mainstream media, black and white, paid attention to in the early 20th century, tended to be college-educated, tall, lean, fair-skinned, handsome, eloquent by the standards of upper-middle-class, white-educated English speech. Marcus Garvey was none of these things. He shows up in Harlem in 1916. He's fairly short, kind of built like a wrestler, very dark, complexed, not a great public speaker. I mean, we know that he got heckled whenever he went to the street corner to try to practice. He was fearless, though. He just kept at it. He had no financial resources. I mean, he lived on cans of corned beef hash and beans in this tiny squalid apartment, while he was beginning to try to interest African Americans in Harlem at this time in his message of pan-African unity, which as it emerged through his speeches and his, uh, his message of pan-African unity. which as it emerged through his speeches and his publication, The Negro World, was, I think it's clear,
领导人，莫莉，他不是一个伟大的演说家，而且有很多批评者。绝对是这样。20世纪初，主流媒体（黑人和白人）关注的非裔美国人领导人往往是受过大学教育、身材高大、精干、肤色较浅、英俊、口才好，符合中上层阶级白人教育英语演讲标准的人。马库斯·加维完全不是这样。他1916年出现在哈莱姆区。他个子不高，身材像个摔跤手，肤色很深，不是一个伟大的公众演说家。我的意思是，我们知道他每次去街角试图练习演讲时都会被起哄。但他无所畏惧。他只是坚持下去。他没有任何经济资源。我的意思是，他住在狭小肮脏的公寓里，靠吃罐装咸牛肉和豆子度日，同时他开始试图让当时哈莱姆区的非裔美国人对他的泛非团结信息感兴趣，随着他的演讲和他的出版物《黑人世界》的传播，我认为很明显，
a really creative combination of previous iterations, of this message of the dignity of African people and the need to unite with other kind of spiritual and economic and political strains that proved to be this kind of. kind of amazing combustible mix, especially when enacted with Garvey's flair for ritual and uniform. He really, he himself loved to wear a plumed helmet and purple gold and green sashes and a kind of military regalia. So this movement over just a few years developed significant momentum.
这是一个非常具有创造性的组合，结合了之前关于非洲人民尊严的信息，以及与其他精神、经济和政治力量联合的需要，事实证明这是一种令人惊叹的易燃混合物，特别是当加维运用他对仪式和制服的品味时。他本人非常喜欢穿戴羽毛头盔和紫金绿色的腰带，以及一种军装。所以这个运动在短短几年内就获得了巨大的动力。
So he also had unconventional views about Black liberation. I want to play you a clip from one of his speeches. We want to unite the liberation in this country. We want everybody to work for one common object but of building a nation of his own on the great continent of Africa. So that recording is not great, Molly, but what he's saying is he wants African-Americans
所以他对黑人解放也有非传统的看法。我想播放一段他演讲的片段。我们想要团结这个国家的解放。我们想要每个人都为一个共同的目标而努力，那就是在广阔的非洲大陆上建立属于他自己的国家。所以那段录音效果不太好，莫莉，但他所说的是他希望非裔美国人，
to leave America and build a homeland in Africa. Now, wasn't that also what white supremacist groups like the Ku Klux Klan might have said? Marcus Garvey was, we would say, a separationist. He had meetings with segregationist politicians from the South, with Ku Klux Klan members, to discuss their mutual interest in keeping their races pure. He wanted, in the context of America, he wanted African Americans to achieve economic autonomy with an eye toward eventually returning to African-Americans.
离开美国，在非洲建立家园。这难道不是像三K党这样的白人至上主义团体可能说过的话吗？马库斯·加维，我们会说，是一个分离主义者。他曾与南方的种族隔离主义政客、三K党成员会面，讨论他们保持种族纯洁的共同利益。在当时美国的背景下，他希望非裔美国人实现经济自主，着眼于最终回到非洲，
and establishing political independence for people of African descent on the African continent. Often, you know, framing it in a way that was rather condescending to the Africans already living there. But it was a message that had a great deal of appeal. And it was a spiritual message as well. I mean, he was very interested in awakening in people of African descent a spiritual power. that he said had been dormant. They had been in a state of amnesia, you could say. When I listen to him and read his speeches,
并为非洲大陆上的非洲裔人民建立政治独立。通常，你知道，他表达的方式对已经生活在那里的非洲人来说相当居高临下。但这确实是一个非常有吸引力的信息。这也是一个精神信息。我的意思是，他非常有兴趣唤醒非洲裔人民内心的一种精神力量，他说这种力量一直处于休眠状态。你可以说他们一直处于失忆状态。当我听他说话并阅读他的演讲稿时，
I hear him as kind of a combination of Moses and Napoleon and Dale Carnegie, the kind of pull yourself up by your own bootstraps aspect of that message. So the effect that he had on his followers was magnified following a very dramatic incident in October 19th. He was in his office in New York when a man burst through the front doors. Tell me the story of what happened next, Molly. This man is clearly in a fury. He's searching for Garvey and is armed. He gets off a couple of rounds and fires at Garvey. Garvey falls to the ground, appears to be mortally wounded. The man takes off and is later captured by police. And it is widely reported that Garvey is killed. And his followers are grief-stricken in mourning.
我听起来他像是摩西、拿破仑和戴尔·卡内基的结合体，那种“靠自己的力量站起来”的信息。所以，在1919年10月发生了一起非常戏剧性的事件后，他对追随者的影响被放大了。当时他在纽约的办公室里，一个人冲破前门。莫莉，告诉我接下来发生了什么。这个人显然处于愤怒之中。他在寻找加维，并且携带武器。他开了几枪，射向加维。加维倒在地上，看起来受了致命伤。那个人逃跑了，后来被警察抓获。广泛报道称加维被杀。他的追随者悲痛欲绝，陷入哀悼。
And then a few days later, Garvey appears limping with a cane to greet his followers at a rally. And many of his followers, especially since they've read these newspaper reports, suggesting that their leader had died, view this as a miraculous, clearly a divinely ordained survival. And so that assassination attempt, if anything, it solidifies Garvey's power over his followers and their faith that God has selected him for a specific mission and that he has a kind of invincibility that ordinary mortals do not have. So we've looked at a spiritual leader in the 18th century and a political leader who was born in the 19th century. Let's jump forward to a completely different world, the world of sports in the 20th century. In the 1960s, Tim Galway was a nationally ranked tennis player. He was captain of the
几天后，加维拄着拐杖一瘸一拐地出现，在集会上迎接他的追随者。许多追随者，特别是考虑到他们读过那些暗示他们的领袖已经死亡的报纸报道，认为这是一个奇迹，显然是神圣注定的幸存。所以那次暗杀企图，如果说有什么影响的话，那就是巩固了加维对追随者的权力，以及他们对上帝选择他执行特定使命的信念，认为他拥有一种凡人所没有的某种无敌感。所以我们看了一位18世纪的精神领袖和一位出生于19世纪的政治领袖。让我们跳到一个完全不同的世界，20世纪的体育世界。20世纪60年代，蒂姆·高威是一名全国排名的网球运动员。他是哈佛网球队的队长。毕业后，他开始在加利福尼亚教网球，但他因其不寻常的教练风格而闻名。莫莉，他的方法是什么？他确实在1974年凭借出版的一本名为《网球内功》的书进入了全国视野。我认为他的信息非常反直觉。本质上，他说，你所有的教练都建议你密切、刻意地关注正手、反手和发球的每一个细节，并深入钻研，直到你完全留意每一个细节。我告诉你，那是错误的方法，成功的网球是一种“自我遗忘”的练习，是让“自我意识”沉默。这是他使用的一个短语。他首先将这种方法应用于网球，然后，
Harvard tennis team. After graduating, he began teaching tennis in California, but he became famous for his unusual coaching style. What was his approach, Molly? He really burst onto National Consciousness in 1974 with a book he published called The Inner Game of Tennis. And his message was quite counterintuitive, I think. Essentially, he said, you've got all these coaches advising you to pay close, deliberate attention to every detail of your forehand and backhand and your serve and to drill down until you're absolutely mindful of every detail. I'm telling you that's the wrong approach, and that successful tennis is an exercise in self-forgetting, in silencing the ego mind. This is a phrase he used. He brought to bear on first tennis and then
在随后的书中应用于其他运动，这是一种佛教和印度教思想的模糊混合，以及20世纪中期关于自我实现的流行心理学概念。所以蒂姆·高威建议，高性能来自于让头脑安静下来，并信任你自然的直觉自我。我想播放一段ABC新闻的片段，其中一位中年女性说，当她参加蒂姆·高威的小组课程时，她已经20年没有做过任何体育运动了。当她开始漂亮地击球时，她自己都感到惊讶。我当时就像漂浮着，你知道，做着自然而然的事情，你知道，我说，啊，我在打网球。这真的很美。《网球内功》中所有练习的关键是将头脑的注意力集中在某个地方，
later sports in subsequent books, kind of vague mix of Buddhist and Hindu ideas, notions from mid-20th century pop psychology regarding self-actualization. So Tim Galway suggested that high performance comes from quieting the mind and trusting your natural intuitive self. I want to play you a clip that ABC News film featuring one middle-aged woman who said that she had not done anything athletic in 20 years when she took part in a group lesson with Tim Galway. She surprised herself when she started to hit the ball beautifully. I was just sort of like floating along, you know, and doing what came naturally, you know, and I said, ah, I'm playing tennis. It's really beautiful. The key of all the exercises in the inner game is to focus the mind's attention somewhere
它不会干扰身体自动击球的能力。所以这个想法有一种奇妙的诱惑力，莫莉。如果我们能摆脱自己的阻碍，你知道，技能就会毫不费力地来到我们身边。没错。而且这种将你的领导者或教练视为帮助你释放潜力的人的想法，即你内心深处存在着真实的自我火焰和真正的能力，它已经存在了。你所要做的就是培养它并释放它。
where it will not interfere with the body's ability to hit the ball automatically. So there's something wonderfully seductive about that idea, Molly. If we can only get out of our own way, you know, skills come to us effortlessly. That's right. And this idea of your leader or your coach as someone who is helping you unlock your potential, that there is inside you this authentic flame of who you really are and your true capabilities, and it's already there. And all you have to do is nurture it and release it.
这是一种非常20世纪末的关于个人身份以及领导者与追随者之间关系的思考方式。当我们思考历史上的强大人物时，很容易通过指出他们独特的个性特征来解释他们的影响力。巴拉克·奥巴马自信而乐观。史蒂夫·乔布斯充满激情且富有远见。马丁·路德·金是一位拥有坚定信念的杰出演说家。
It's a very late 20th century way of thinking about personal identity and the relationship between leaders and followers. When we think about powerful figures in history, it's easy to explain their influence, by pointing to their unique personality traits. Barack Obama was confident and optimistic. Steve Jobs was intense and visionary. Martin Luther King, Jr. was a brilliant speaker with strong convictions.
但这是我们没有探索的故事的重要部分。那就是魅力型人物如何唤醒我们内心某种东西的故事。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们经常将魅力与讨人喜欢混为一谈。当我们想到有魅力的人时，我们会想到那些拥有美丽笑容、出色社交技巧和引人共鸣背景的人。
But it's an important part of the story we don't explore. That is the story of how charismatic people awake something in us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We often conflate charisma with likability. When we think about charismatic people, we think of people with beautiful smiles, great social skills, and relatable backgrounds.
像约翰·肯尼迪、玛丽莲·梦露或奥普拉这样的人。在北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校，历史学家莫莉·沃森提出了不同的观点。她说，历史上的魅力型人物并不总是迷人或美丽，甚至不总是鼓舞人心。相反，她认为，我们被他们吸引，不是因为他们的特质，而是因为他们向我们揭示了关于我们自己的某些东西。
People like John F. Kennedy, Marilyn Monroe, or Oprah. At the University of North Carolina, Chapel Hill, historian Molly Worthen offers a different view. She says that charismatic people in history aren't always charming or beautiful, or even inspirational. Rather, she argues, we are drawn to them, not because of their traits, but because they reveal something to us about ourselves.
莫莉，我想先了解你使用“魅力”这个词时的含义，这可能会有所帮助。这个词的历史是什么？如果我们回到古希腊人使用这个词的方式，并将其传给《圣经》作者的方式，最好将魅力（charisma）或“恩典”（caris）视为一种恩典，一种来自上帝或众神的礼物，在古希腊语境中，它带来了可能产生好坏影响的力量。这是接受者，
Molly, I think it might help to first understand what you mean when you use the term charisma. What is the history of this word? If we go back to the way the ancient Greeks used the word and bequeathed it to the authors of the Bible, it's best to think of charisma or caris as a kind of grace, a gift from God or the gods that in the ancient Greek context brought with it power that could redound for good or for ill. It was power that the recipient
无法完全控制的力量，一种人类接受者未必要求的礼物。这个词在基督教神学语境中保留了整整1900年。我的意思是，它是一个相当晦涩的术语。只有当你非常活跃于教会，或者你是专业的教会历史学家或神学家时，你才会有机会使用或了解它。莫莉，这个词是如何变得世俗化的？20世纪之交，德国社会学家马克斯·韦伯正在寻找描述所有复杂变化的方法。
could not completely control, a gift that the human recipient didn't necessarily ask for. And the word remained in that Christian theological context for really 1900 years. I mean, It was a fairly obscure term. You would only have occasion to use it or know it if you were very active in church or you were a professional church historian or theologian. How did the term come to be secularized, Molly? Around the turn of the 20th century, the German sociologist Max Weber was casting about looking for ways to describe all the complicated changes.
他看到这些变化在西方现代性中展开。他非常关注领导力，以及特定个人如何转变为破坏性力量的方式。所以他借用了“魅力”这个词。他在学生时代的一次讲座中听到了这个词，那是一次关于教会历史的讲座。他借用它来描述他在宗教中，但也重要地在政治中看到的一种特定权威，他说这种权威，
He was seeing unfold in Western modernity. He was really interested in leadership and in the way particular individuals could turn into disruptive forces. So he borrowed the term charisma. He heard it in a lecture when he was a student, a lecture in church history. And he borrowed it to describe a particular kind of authority that he saw manifest in both religion but also importantly in politics, a type of authority that he said. said was different from authority based on institutions, like the institutional role of a president or a prime minister, different from authority premised on a society's tradition, and separate too from authority that comes with military power. Charisma instead is the quality of an individual seen by his followers, that this leader has superhuman qualities. And the
与基于制度的权威（如总统或总理的制度角色）不同，与基于社会传统的权威不同，也与伴随军事力量的权威分开。相反，魅力是追随者眼中个人的一种品质，即这位领导者拥有超人的品质。因此，
therefore can promise for them a new path forward that is totally impossible except for his leadership. By the late 1950s and the 1960s, American journalists start picking it up and kind of playing with the word charisma as a way to describe contemporary politics here. When I think of the word charisma, Molly, I often associated with people who are magnetic. Has that been a part of the meaning of the word for a long time? I think one reason the word charisma is so interesting is because it's a term we punt to when we are observing a dynamic between a leader and followers that we can't quite make sense of.
他可以为他们承诺一条新的前进道路，除了他的领导之外，这条道路是完全不可能的。到了20世纪50年代末和60年代，美国记者开始使用这个词，并以某种方式玩弄“魅力”这个词，作为描述这里当代政治的一种方式。当我想到“魅力”这个词时，莫莉，我经常把它与那些有磁性的人联系起来。这在很长一段时间里是这个词含义的一部分吗？我认为“魅力”这个词之所以如此有趣，原因之一是因为当我们观察领导者和追随者之间我们无法完全理解的动态时，我们就会求助于这个术语。
We know something's going on, but we can't account for it by pointing to a policy proposal that this person is making or, some other kind of common sense quid pro quo arrangement. And I think as Americans have played with the word charisma, it's gotten a bit muddled together with the ideas of charm and celebrity. And it surprised me to observe how few of the figures I ended up studying across four centuries of American history were particularly charming. I found myself again and again writing about individuals who who were not that good looking, who were not reported to be amazing public speakers,
我们知道发生了什么，但我们无法通过指出此人正在提出的政策建议或某种其他常见的利益交换安排来解释它。我认为，随着美国人玩弄“魅力”这个词，它与魅力（charm）和名人效应（celebrity）的概念混在一起了。令我惊讶的是，我研究的四个世纪美国历史中，很少有几个人特别迷人。我发现自己一次又一次地写到那些，那些长相并不出众，据报道也不是出色的公众演说家，
whose presence was maybe better described as polarizing rather than kind of universally magnetic. You know, if we think about people who are really good at, you know, working the room at a cocktail party, they have the ability to invite you into a conversation that quickly starts to feel like an exploration. of your own best thoughts and experiences. I think that's really the secret of charm. And it's important, but it is not enough to launch a new religion or build a political movement. The leaders who do that, I think, have to offer something much more powerful
他们的存在可能被描述为两极分化，而不是普遍具有磁性。你知道，如果我们想到那些非常擅长在鸡尾酒会上活跃气氛的人，他们有能力邀请你进入一场很快就开始感觉像是探索你内心最好想法和经历的对话。我认为这才是魅力的秘诀。这很重要，但不足以发起一场新宗教或建立一场政治运动。我认为，做到这一点的领导者必须提供更强大的东西，
and disorienting and compelling. Can you talk a moment about the very interesting idea that likability can actually be an impediment if you're trying to break through social norms and customs. Humans are storytelling and storymaking creatures. We're constantly looking for ways to organize our chaos. And the most successful politicians and religious leaders are brilliant storytellers,
更令人困惑和引人注目的东西。你能谈谈“讨人喜欢实际上可能成为打破社会规范和习俗的障碍”这个非常有趣的观点吗？人类是讲故事和创造故事的生物。我们一直在寻找组织混乱的方法。最成功的政治家和宗教领袖是出色的讲故事者，
who not only offer a set of slogans, a critique of the other side, But a plot arc, a story of where we have come and where we're going, who the villains are, who the heroes are, and they invite certain people in. But a narrative only has tension. It's only worth being a part of it. If there are also people who don't belong, or who are cast in rather undesirable roles. So I think if a leader is too preoccupied with being all things to all people, that can result in a message that is not activating, that doesn't grab and elevate a certain subset of the people hearing or reading him to the point of really building a movement. Really breaking through and building a movement is going to involve eliciting quite a lot. lot of disdain and anger from people who are not part of the story you're telling.
他们不仅提供了一套口号、对他方的批评，还有一个情节弧线，一个关于我们从哪里来、我们要到哪里去、谁是反派、谁是英雄的故事，他们邀请特定的人加入。但叙事只有在有张力的情况下才成立。只有当也有人“不属于”或者被分配到相当不受欢迎的角色时，它才值得参与。所以我认为，如果一个领导者太专注于成为“所有人的所有东西”，那可能会导致一个无法激活的信息，它不会抓住并提升听到或阅读他的那部分人，使其达到真正建立运动的程度。真正突破并建立运动将涉及引发那些不属于你所讲故事的人的相当多的蔑视和愤怒。
You say that there is a paradox of charisma, and it has to do with the dual urges we have to feel like we are in control of our lives, but also to fear the responsibility that comes from having that control. Can you unpack that idea for me, Molly? Most of us want some feeling of agency, some sense that we know what the point of all of this struggling and suffering is, that it hasn't been for no reason at all. But we don't quite want the responsibility of being wholly in charge of it all ourselves. And those two impulses, you know, wanting that sense of freedom and control, but also wanting that security, they exist in tension. But I think that they're always there. And the most successful, at least briefly,
你说存在一种“魅力的悖论”，它与我们既想感觉自己掌控生活，又害怕拥有这种控制权所带来的责任的双重冲动有关。莫莉，你能为我解析这个想法吗？我们大多数人都想要某种代理感，某种感觉，即我们知道所有这些挣扎和痛苦的意义是什么，它并非毫无理由。但我们并不完全想要完全掌控这一切的责任。这两种冲动，你知道，想要那种自由和控制感，但也想要那种安全感，它们存在于张力之中。但我认为它们一直都在那里。最成功的，至少在短期内，
not always over the long term, but those religious and political movements that have really made a mark on American history have been led by individuals who mastered the art of that balance. You see that the religious leader Joseph Smith exemplifies this paradox. How so, Molly? Joseph Smith was a child of kind of poor New England, home. homesteader, family members who couldn't really make a comfortable life in the context of, you know, the turn of the 19th century America. They were constantly scrapping and struggling to make a living materially. And also, you know, his parents were seekers who were frustrated with existing church options, really interested in the supernatural side of life, prone to having dreams,
并不总是从长远来看，但那些在历史上真正留下印记的宗教和政治运动，都是由掌握了这种平衡艺术的个人领导的。你认为宗教领袖约瑟夫·史密斯就是这种悖论的典范。莫莉，怎么说？约瑟夫·史密斯是新英格兰贫困家庭的孩子，家庭成员在19世纪之交的美国背景下无法过上舒适的生活。他们一直在物质上挣扎求生。而且，你知道，他的父母是寻求者，对现有的教会选择感到沮丧，对生活的超自然方面非常感兴趣，容易做梦，
and visions, but unable to really find an institutional home. And that's awfully confusing and disorienting. Joseph Smith had this genius. I mean, Mormons would say he, you know, he received revelation that helped him to diagnose the gaps, the ways in which the existing religious story, way of understanding the Bible and the relationship between humans and God was just leaving, I guess, a critical mass of early Americans feeling frustrated and lost. And so he offers, as he's reporting his revelations and interpreting these golden plates that he says he's been led to find in a hill in upstate New York by the angel Maroni. And then he's spent, the next two years kind of spinning out what this new religious community built around this new
和幻象，但无法真正找到一个制度性的家。这非常令人困惑和迷失方向。约瑟夫·史密斯有这种天赋。我的意思是，摩门教徒会说他，你知道，他接受了启示，帮助他诊断了差距，即现有的宗教故事、理解《圣经》的方式以及人类与上帝之间关系的方式，只是让一大批早期美国人感到沮丧和迷失。所以他提供了，当他报告他的启示并解释这些金页片时，他说他被天使摩罗乃引导在纽约州北部的一座山上找到。然后他花了接下来的两年时间，阐述这个围绕这个新，
scripture will look like. In many ways, he offers a deeply American form of Christianity that is very much in line, I think, with the desires and anxieties of Americans at this time. They want to have their free will celebrated. recognized. And the Mormon faith is kind of the ultimate free will faith. I mean, it's very clear in offering a roadmap for earning your exaltation and your access essentially to different stages of heaven. So it is this, it's this story of both tremendous empowerment, but also an invitation to subsume your individual struggles and your efforts to scratch out an existence on your little homestead in upstate New York or Ohio into this broader story that God has ordained
经文建立的新宗教社区会是什么样子。在许多方面，他提供了一种深刻的美国式基督教，我认为这非常符合当时美国人的欲望和焦虑。他们希望自己的自由意志得到庆祝和认可。摩门教信仰是一种终极的自由意志信仰。我的意思是，它在提供赚取你的升华和进入天堂不同阶段的路线图方面非常明确。所以这是一个关于巨大赋权的故事，也是一个邀请，将你在纽约州北部或俄亥俄州小农场上挣扎求生的个人奋斗和努力，融入到上帝以某种有意义的方式注定的更广泛的故事中。所以，我认为这是那个悖论的一个很好的例子，既提供了赋权的代理感，也提供了安全感。然而，当你说话时，莫莉，我感到非常清楚，当魅力型人物拥有这些追随者时，很明显他们拥有这些追随者是因为他们正在解锁他们所领导的人内心的某种东西。人们在这些信息中听到了关于他们自己的某种东西。所以，你知道，即使魅力型领导者不迷人、不英俊、不讨人喜欢，重点是这个信息让我对自己有了不同的思考。没错。约瑟夫·史密斯就是一个很好的例子。我的意思是，一些亲眼见过他的人发现他，
in some meaningful way. And so that, I think, is a great example of that paradox, of offering both empowering agency and security. As you're talking, though, Molly, it feels so clear to me that when charismatic people have these followings, it's clear they have these followings because they're unlocking something in the people who they are leading. The people are hearing something about themselves in this message. So it's, you know, even if the charismatic leader is not charming and is not good looking and is not likable, the point is the message makes me think differently about myself. That's right. And Joseph Smith is a great example of this. I mean, some people who met him in person found him,
在身体上确实很有吸引力。他在那个时代算高的。他有那种电蓝色的眼睛。一位追随者说，仅仅通过握手，她就感到圣灵电击了她的全身。但你也可以找到怀疑论者，
really physically compelling. He was tall for the era. He had these electric blue eyes. One follower said just, by shaking his hand, she felt the Holy Spirit electrify her whole body. But then you can also find skeptics
他们遇到他并说，这家伙是个小丑。他有一张不诚实的脸。他的手有点胖。我才不会跟着他去杂货店，更不用说像他的追随者在伊利诺伊州纳吾那样，在密西西比河岸边建立一个新的锡安。约瑟夫·史密斯的经历也是一个早期的案例，帮助我在研究中理解，
who encounter him and say, this guy is a clown. He has this dishonest face. His hands are kind of fat. I wouldn't follow him to the grocery store, let alone to, found a new Zion on the banks of the Mississippi, as his followers did in Navu, Illinois. And Joseph Smith's story also was an early case that helped me understand in my research,
魅力的力量更多地存在于故事和信息中，而不是个人身上。你探索的魅力元素之一是，魅力型人物经常承诺揭开一个秘密真相的面纱。我的意思是，杰迈玛·威尔金森是这样，马库斯·加维是这样，甚至蒂姆·高威也是这样。谈谈这个想法，即在某种程度上，魅力型人物，
that the power of charisma resides much more in the story and the message than in the individual. One of the elements of charisma that you explore is that charismatic people often promised to pull back the veil on a secret truth. I mean, that was true of Jemima Wilkinson, that was true of Marcus Garvey, even true of Tim Galway. Talk about this idea that in some ways charismatic people
提议向我们展示一种在某种程度上位于我们每天看到的现实背后的现实愿景。我认为在许多不同背景下的魅力型领导者，都在将自己与人们从既定来源获得的信息并列。
offer to show us a vision of reality that is in some ways behind the reality that we are seeing every day. I think charismatic leaders in many different contexts are positioning themselves alongside the message that people are getting from established sources.
从传统、从制度中获得的信息，而魅力型领导者说，你以为有人告诉你世界是如何运作的。你以为你对现实有一个完整的画面。但你没有。你被剥夺了一些关于你的存在以及你与物质和超自然力量之间关系的关键事实。这可以采取一种非常合法的启示形式，即真正获得作为人类的完整画面的途径。所以我认为这是我们可以理解马丁·路德·金信息的一种方式，他是一个通过重新定位美国人（黑人和白人）看待可能性的方式，看待每个人作为个体的现实，以及20世纪中期黑人美国人的生活经历与正义真正包含的内容之间的巨大鸿沟，从而打破了自满情绪的人。所以这是一个揭开面纱的案例，它绝对植根于一个真实的启示，如果你愿意的话。
from tradition, from institutions, and the charismatic leader says, you think you've been told how the world works. You think you have a full picture of reality. But you don't. You've been denied some crucial facts about your existence and your relationship to the powers, both material and supernatural. And that can take the form of a very legitimate revelation. of true access to the full picture of what it is to be human. So I think this is one way we could understand Martin Luther King Jr.'s message, that he is someone who destabilized complacently
但我认为这也可以采取更黑暗的形式。这就是我认为“魅力”这个词可能会在我们的脑海中触发某种负面含义的地方，因为它有时会伴随着一个关于现实的虚假故事。一种试图破坏人们从主流媒体接收到的新闻，或者他们被专家告知的内容的努力。有时这可能会跨越到某种伪事实的领域。所以，我认为我们在日常生活中如何使用这些信息，我们如何评估领导者，至关重要的是要不断地将领导者告诉我们的故事与其他信息来源进行对比，并尽我们所能（尽管在这方面做到完美是不可能的）去辨别：这位领导者是否真的在向我展示一些真实的东西，并且改变了一切，
and a willingness to just suffer Jim Crow by reorienting the way that Americans, black and white, saw what was possible, saw the reality of, of who each person is as an individual and the vast chasm between the lived experience of black Americans in the mid-20th century and what justice really consists of. So there is a case of a pulling back the veil that it was absolutely rooted in a true revelation, if you will.
并且我必须认真对待，或者我是否有理由持怀疑态度？魅力是一种强大的力量。它有能力激励、团结并赋予人们深刻的意义感和目标感。当一个有魅力的人说话时，他们的追随者听到的不仅仅是一场演讲。他们正在看到一种理解自己生活的新方式。当我们回来时，魅力多年来采取的不同形式，以及我们应该如何以及何时质疑它。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你是否有关于被魅力型领导者吸引的个人故事？关于魅力以及我们如何被一个，
But I think this can take darker forms also. And this is where I think the word charisma can trigger perhaps in our mind a kind of negative connotation because it can sometimes go along with a false story about reality. A, an effort to undermine, you know, the news people receive from the mainstream media or, you know, what they're told by experts. And sometimes that can cross over into the realm of kind of pseudo facts. So really crucial, I think, in how we use this information in our everyday lives, how we evaluate leaders, is to be constantly holding up the story that leaders tell us against other sources of information and doing our best, although it's never possible to be perfect at this, to discern, is this leader really showing me something that is true and that changes every
迷人的人的咒语所吸引的问题？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的问题或故事，请在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录。然后，将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“Charisma”。再说一遍，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。魅力型人物吸引追随者，塑造运动，并改变国家的进程。在北卡罗来纳大学，历史学家莫莉·沃森是《着迷：魅力如何塑造美国历史，从清教徒到唐纳德·特朗普》一书的作者。莫莉，我想知道你是否可以谈谈魅力型人物有时会将他们的个人故事与他们的信息融合在一起的想法。例如，在唐纳德·特朗普成为总统很久之前，他就在精心策划，
everything and that I have to take seriously, or perhaps do I have reason to be skeptical? Charisma is a powerful force. It has the ability to inspire, unite, and give people a profound sense of meaning and purpose. When a charismatic person speaks, their followers aren't just hearing a speech. They are seeing a new way to understand their own lives. When we come back, the different forms that charisma has taken over the years and how and when we should question it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do you have personal stories about being drawn in by a charismatic leader? A question about charisma and how we can be swept up in the spell of a
一个将个人神话与他的世界观融合在一起的叙事，即美国正被世界其他国家利用。你能谈谈魅力型人物非常擅长将自己置于他们正在精心策划的故事和叙事流中的想法吗？我认为这完全正确，对于一个提供旨在将追随者吸引到与他或她作为个人建立特殊关系的叙事中的魅力型领导者来说，这是一个关键步骤。回顾唐纳德·特朗普在正式进入政坛之前的职业生涯，我认为他表现出了这样做的真正本能。如果你回去阅读他在20世纪80年代与小报记者的谈话，或者你可以在20世纪80年代末的奥普拉·温弗瑞秀上找到他的旧录像。你会发现他在谈论他与各种邪恶行为者的经历，
mesmerizing person? If you'd be willing to share your question or story with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone. Then, email the file. to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, Charisma. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Charismatic people draw followers in, shape movements, and alter the course of nations. At the University of North Carolina, historian Molly Worthen is the author of Spellbound, how Charisma shaped American history from the Puritans to Donald Trump. Molly, I'm wondering whether you can talk about the idea that charismatic people sometimes fuse their personal story with their message. So long before Donald Trump became president, for example, he was crafting
他们试图利用他并敲诈他。这是他职业生涯早期经常使用的一个短语。我认为人们厌倦了看到美国被敲诈。我不能向你们承诺一切。但我可以告诉你们一件事。这个国家会从那些25年来一直利用我们的人那里赚到一大笔钱，情况不会再是以前那样了。相信我。他对自己的描述是一个白手起家的男人，你知道，掩盖了他从父亲那里继承商业帝国的程度。
a narrative that fused personal mythology with his worldview that America was being taken advantage off by the rest of the world. Can you talk about this idea that charismatic people are very good at placing themselves in the flow of the stories and the narratives that they're crafting? I think that's exactly right and a crucial step for a charismatic leader who's offering a story that is supposed to draw followers into a special relationship with him or her as an individual. Looking back over Donald Trump's career long before he formally entered politics, I think he showed a real instinct for doing this. And if you go back and read his conversations with tabloid reporters in the 1980s, Or you can find old footage of him on the Oprah Winfrey show in the late 1980s. And you find him talking about his experience with all kinds of evil actors
相反，他将其描述为一种辉煌的创业创造力练习，这种练习要求他在每一个转折点都避开那些试图打倒他的人，并且要求他发展出一种操纵体制的能力，因为体制从根本上是腐败的。为什么没有合法性的法律值得始终如一的、善意的尊重？我认为这是一个他一直非常小心地走的路线，他从未在他自己的职业生涯叙事中暗示他违反了任何法律。但与此同时，暗示如果有人不利用税法中的漏洞，如果你不这样做，那么你就是一个傻瓜。所以，你知道，他精心策划了这个关于他自己作为这种操纵体制和复仇大师的故事。
who have tried to take advantage of him and rip him off. That's a phrase he uses a lot from early in his career. I think people are tired of seeing the United States ripped off. And I can't promise you everything. But I can tell you one thing. This country would make one hell of a lot of money. from those people that for 25 years have taken advantage, it wouldn't be the way it's been. Believe me. His account is one of himself as a self-made man, you know, really glossing over the degree to which he inherited his business empire from his father.
那些试图占他便宜并欺骗他的人。这是他职业生涯早期经常使用的一个短语。我认为人们已经厌倦了看到美国被占便宜。我不能向你们承诺一切，但我可以告诉你们一件事：这个国家会从那些二十五年来一直占便宜的人身上赚到一大笔钱，情况不会再像过去那样了。相信我。他将自己描述为一个白手起家的人，你知道，这实际上掩盖了他从父亲那里继承商业帝国的程度。
And instead, he describes it as this brilliant exercise in entrepreneurial creativity, one that has required him to evade at every turn, people who would try. to take him down, and it's required him to develop a facility in working the system because the system is fundamentally corrupt. And why do laws that have no legitimacy deserve consistent, you know, good faith respect? That's a line he's always walked very carefully, I think, never, never suggesting in his own narrative of his career that he broke any laws. But at the same time, suggesting that someone who doesn't take advantage of, you know, loopholes in the tax code, if you don't do all of those things, then you're kind of a fool. So, you know, he has crafted this story of himself as this master of this kind of working the system and taking revenge
相反，他将其描述为一种卓越的创业创造力实践，这种实践要求他在每一个转折点都避开那些试图打倒他的人，并要求他培养出一种利用体制的能力，因为这个体制从根本上是腐败的。既然那些没有合法性的法律，为什么要给予一贯的、善意的尊重呢？我认为他一直非常小心地把握着这条界限，在他的职业生涯叙述中，从未暗示过自己触犯了任何法律。但与此同时，他又暗示，如果一个人不利用税法中的漏洞，如果你不做所有这些事情，那你就是一个傻瓜。所以，你知道，他把自己塑造成了一个精通利用体制并进行报复的大师形象。
on people who are bad actors. And so it was really not a far leap at all. to cast himself as he trained his eye on national politics as the hero of the forgotten man, of the hero who would really rectify injustices and go after all of the people and the powers and the institutions that are rigged against the average American that have screwed people over, to use another phrase that he's used frequently. And so he set himself. up, I think, quite brilliantly, to fuse his personal story of triumph in the business world with the revenge and justice and ultimate triumph that he promised to offer his supporters
针对那些行为不端的人。因此，他将自己塑造成“被遗忘者的英雄”，一个真正能纠正不公正、打击那些针对普通美国人的权力机构和既得利益者，以及那些“坑害”民众（用他常用的一个词）的人的英雄，这对他来说一点也不难。我认为他非常巧妙地将自己在商业世界中取得成功的个人故事，与他承诺为支持者提供的复仇、正义和最终胜利融合在了一起。
if they elected him president. Do you think his story in some ways mirrors the stories of other people that you have looked at, other charismatic people, and that, you know, there are followers of his who, you know, almost quite literally are willing to die for him and believe so deeply in what he stands for. And simultaneously, there are other people who look at him and don't know whether to roll their eyes or just to throw their hands up in disgust. You know, he seems to evoke extremely strong passions in completely different directions. Absolutely. And it was observing those very polarized reactions back in 2015 that helped send me down the path of trying to understand the phenomenon
如果他们选他当总统的话。你认为他的故事在某种程度上是否反映了你研究过的其他人的故事，那些同样具有魅力的人？你知道，他的追随者中，有些人几乎真的愿意为他去死，并且对他所代表的理念深信不疑。与此同时，另一些人看着他，不知道该翻白眼还是该因厌恶而摊手。你知道，他似乎在完全不同的方向上激起了极其强烈的热情。绝对是这样。正是2015年观察到这些极其两极分化的反应，促使我走上了试图理解这种现象的道路。
of charisma across the centuries. And I absolutely, did find that that polarizing effect on people is echoed, you know, all the way back into colonial times up into, up into the present. I'm wondering, Molly, when you think about someone like Donald Trump, you know, his views have actually been fairly consistent about some of these issues for a long period of time and well before he became president. His sense, of course, that he's being ripped off, that the country's being ripped off, that you have to, you know, take on these institutions and these elite forces that are, you know, arrayed against the common man. These are all views that he's held
跨越几个世纪的魅力现象。我确实发现，这种对人们的两极分化影响，从殖民时代一直延续到今天，都有所回响。莫莉，当你想起像唐纳德·特朗普这样的人时，你知道，他在很长一段时间里，甚至在他成为总统之前，对其中一些问题的看法其实是相当一致的。当然，他认为自己被坑了，国家被坑了，你必须去对抗那些针对普通人的机构和精英势力。这些都是他长期持有的观点。
for a long time. Do you think that charismatic people carefully select their views to figure out what will be effective in driving their followers? Or are they really accidents of history? Which is that they happen to have a set of views and beliefs and perhaps even personal stories. And these happen to fit almost like a key into a lock into the needs of the people who are around them at the time. That's a great question. And I think the charismatic leaders have to have a kind of genius
你认为有魅力的人会仔细选择他们的观点，以找出什么能有效地驱动他们的追随者吗？还是说他们只是历史的偶然？也就是说，他们恰好拥有一套观点和信仰，甚至可能是个人故事。而这些恰好像钥匙插进锁孔一样，契合了当时周围人们的需求。这是一个很好的问题。我认为有魅力的领导者必须拥有一种天赋。
and an instinct for reading their time and identifying the driving anxieties and desires of their cultural moment, especially among people who are not being served by the narratives currently on offer in the culture. But I have never run across a character charismatic leader who struck me as 100% pragmatic and just adopting, you know, some mix of views and making up some story willy-nilly purely because it seems like it will play well.
以及一种解读时代、识别文化时刻中驱动性焦虑和欲望的本能，尤其是对于那些在当前文化叙事中得不到满足的人群而言。但我从未遇到过一个让我觉得是百分之百务实、仅仅为了看起来效果好而随意拼凑观点和编造故事的魅力型领导者。
Instead, I think you're right that there has to be this kind of magic, this synergy between the leader's natural self-understanding and aspects of his or her own story. and the way he connects specific parts of that story to this grander picture. As a reminder, if you have questions or comments for Molly Worthen that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org.
相反，我认为你是对的，领导者天生的自我认知与他或她自身故事的各个方面之间，必须存在一种魔力，一种协同效应。以及他将那个故事的特定部分与更宏大的图景联系起来的方式。提醒一下，如果您有任何想与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，用手机录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将文件发送至Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, Charisma. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Molly says that we live today in the age of the guru. I asked her what defines this type of charismatic leader. I think it's interesting to play with the term guru in a broad sense. And to remember, too, that charismatic leadership very rarely exists in a pure form. It's often combined with other kinds of authority. So the frame of the guru as a radically...
邮件主题请写“Charisma”（魅力）。再说一遍，是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。莫莉说我们今天生活在“大师”时代。我问她是什么定义了这种类型的魅力型领导者。我认为从广义上玩味“大师”这个词很有趣。也要记住，魅力型领导力很少以纯粹的形式存在。它通常与其他类型的权威相结合。所以，将“大师”视为一个激进的……
anti-institutional figure, who is positioning himself as the gateway to truth and knowledge. That's a useful frame, I think, for understanding Donald Trump, while, of course, also recognizing that he has conventional institutional authority as the president of the United States. But I think it's a broader cultural phenomenon that we can see, manifest across the political spectrum, I became fascinated by the story of Oprah Winfrey and the kind of personal do-it-yourself spirituality that she developed alongside her media career. And I think much of her effectiveness and popularity, you know, really rocketing to fame in the mid-1980s when she was in her 30s lay in her ability to continue.
反体制人物，将自己定位为通往真理和知识的门户。我认为，这对于理解唐纳德·特朗普是一个有用的框架，当然，也要承认他作为美国总统拥有传统的制度权威。但我认为这是一种更广泛的文化现象，我们可以看到它在整个政治光谱中都有体现。我开始对奥普拉·温弗瑞的故事，以及她在媒体生涯之外发展出的那种个人化的“自助式”灵性产生了浓厚兴趣。我认为她之所以能如此有效且受欢迎，你知道，在20世纪80年代中期她30多岁时迅速成名，很大程度上在于她能够持续地……
convince many Americans that what you were seeing on her show was, was her authentic self. It was, it was just, you know, straight shooting, asking the difficult questions, pulling back the veil on reality that, you know, more polite talk show hosts would ignore. I say this on my show all the time. Can you really forgive if you haven't gotten angry, if you haven't dealt with how you really feel? I don't know if you can go from having been abused to forgiveness. But it becomes folded into this broader story of how you should be in the world that draws on various new age religious influences, you know, Deepak Chopra and really a kind of, she's a sort of omnivorous consumer of all kinds of religious and spiritual tools, you know, everything. from her own Christian heritage, you know, what she grew up with, to more kind of Eastern
让许多美国人相信，你在她的节目中看到的是她真实的自我。那只是，你知道，直言不讳，提出尖锐的问题，揭开现实的面纱，而那些更客气的脱口秀主持人会忽略这些。我在我的节目中一直这么说。如果你没有发过火，如果你没有处理过你真实的感受，你真的能原谅吗？我不知道一个人在遭受虐待后是否能直接走向宽恕。但这被纳入了关于你应该如何在世界上生存的更宏大的故事中，这个故事借鉴了各种新时代宗教的影响，你知道，迪帕克·乔普拉，她实际上是一个各种宗教和灵性工具的“杂食性”消费者，你知道，从她自己的基督教传统，也就是她成长过程中所接触的，到更……
religious techniques, to just a way of talking about shopping and acquisition as self-empowerment and a way of actualizing your potential. These are all a way of recasting religion, not as joining a traditional community, you know, deciding to obey an institution, But rather, think of it as a toolbox or a smorgasbord, if you will, of options that are just all about suiting yourself. Because only you have the power to take responsibility to move your life forward. And so it's a whole picture of reality that I think she offered her most devoted fans. And that's part of why you encounter in Oprah's fans a sense that this, woman is laying out a path, a way of being. You know, she's not just a talk show host. So I think
东方宗教技巧，再到仅仅是一种将购物和获取视为自我赋权和实现潜能的方式。这些都是重塑宗教的方式，不是加入一个传统社区，你知道，决定服从一个机构，而是把它想象成一个工具箱，或者如果你愿意的话，一个自助餐，里面有各种选项，一切都为了适合你自己。因为只有你有力量承担责任，推动你的生活向前发展。所以我认为她向她最忠实的粉丝提供的是一幅完整的现实图景。这就是为什么你在奥普拉的粉丝中会感受到一种感觉，这个女人正在铺设一条道路，一种生存方式。你知道，她不仅仅是一个脱口秀主持人。所以我认为……
that frame of the guru helps us make sense of this whole cultural picture and people as disparate as Donald Trump and Oprah. I think what I'm struggling with Molly is, you know, I'm trying to imagine what if I was, you know, somebody living in Nazi Germany in 1936. And this messian leader comes along and basically tells me a story about, you know, lost glory and the glory that is achievable if Germany were to achieve its full potential. And I'm inspired by the story, and I want to follow this person. What should I be doing when I feel like I'm gripped by somebody who has the story that feels like it's unlocking something within me? And I feel like I need to follow this person. What are the questions I should ask myself that, you know, I don't have the
“大师”这个框架有助于我们理解整个文化图景，以及像唐纳德·特朗普和奥普拉这样迥异的人。莫莉，我感到困惑的是，你知道，我试着想象如果我是1936年生活在纳粹德国的人。然后这位弥赛亚式的领导者出现了，基本上给我讲了一个关于失落的荣耀，以及如果德国能发挥其全部潜力就能实现的荣耀的故事。我被这个故事激励了，我想追随这个人。当我感觉自己被一个故事所吸引，而这个故事似乎解开了我内心深处的东西时，我该怎么做？我觉得我需要追随这个人。我应该问自己什么问题，你知道，我没有……
luxury of hindsight, of waiting 30 years to see how something has turned out. But in the moment, what kind of question should I ask myself to determine if I'm on the right path? Boy, that is in some ways the question, right? And I think part of what your question has to compel in all of us is a recognition that even in these cases that in hindsight seem kind of black and white morally, if you're in it, it can be very hard to tell, you know, up from down and get your moral bearings. I guess I have two main thoughts. One is that there's a real power to being embedded enough in a long-standing, ancient philosophical or religious tradition that you can avail yourself of all of its resources and perspectives on a range of different challenges in
事后诸葛亮的奢侈，没有30年的时间去观察事情的结果。但在当下，我应该问自己什么样的问题来确定我是否走在正确的道路上？天哪，这在某种程度上就是那个问题，对吧？我认为你的问题必须促使我们所有人认识到，即使在那些事后看来道德上非黑即白的案例中，如果你身处其中，也很难分辨是非，找到道德准绳。我想我有两个主要的想法。第一，深深扎根于一个长期存在的、古老的哲学或宗教传统中，并利用其所有资源和视角来应对一系列不同的挑战，这具有真正的力量。
human experience. So when I think about the small number of German Christians who resisted the Nazis and remained deeply critical of Hitler, even in the case of Dietrich Bonhofer attempting to assassinate him, I see that clarity of moral vision as a reflection of staying grounded in the whole of the tradition, not whatever kind of attenuated, useful version. of this old tradition, the leader happens to be endorsing. The second needful thing is to ask, who is this charismatic leader casting as my enemy? Who is he telling me as the villain? And what do I actually know about those people?
人类经验。所以当我想到少数抵制纳粹并对希特勒保持深刻批判的德国基督徒时，即使是迪特里希·朋霍费尔试图暗杀他的案例，我看到那种道德愿景的清晰，反映了扎根于整个传统，而不是领导者恰好支持的某种被削弱的、有用的版本。第二件必要的事情是问：这个魅力型领导者将谁塑造成了我的敌人？他在告诉我谁是恶棍？而我对这些人到底了解多少？
What are my sources of information? In most cases, right? I mean, that set of questions was not at top of mind for Germans, you know, who were looking the other way or directly complicit in the Holocaust. But for the minority that helped save Jews and worked in the resistance, that personal knowledge of these victims as individuals, as, you know, multidimensional humans was absolutely crucial in inoculating them against Hitler's. anti-Semitic propaganda. So, you know, in our current moment, and, you know, I don't, I certainly don't want to accidentally draw analogies. I think we always have to be very careful in drawing historical analogies. But certainly we live in a time when very few Americans know in a personal way
我的信息来源是什么？在大多数情况下，对吧？我的意思是，那套问题在那些视而不见或直接参与大屠杀的德国人脑海中并不是首要考虑的。但对于那些帮助拯救犹太人并参与抵抗运动的少数人来说，将这些受害者视为个体、视为多维人类的个人认知，对于让他们免受希特勒反犹太宣传的影响至关重要。所以，你知道，在我们当前的时刻，而且，我当然不想意外地进行类比。我认为我们在进行历史类比时必须非常小心。但我们确实生活在一个很少有美国人以个人方式了解……
people who are on the other side of this political divide. And those relationships are are hard to come by for all kinds of reasons. But at the very least, even if we don't have access to those relationships, we can remind ourselves of that dearth of information, the fact that human beings are complicated, and any kind of monolithic story of the other side has to obscure far more than it clarifies. In the best of times, charismatic people can make a chaotic world feel more orderly. They can imbue our daily lives with purpose and meaning. They make us feel good,
政治分歧另一方的人的时代。由于各种原因，这些关系很难建立。但至少，即使我们无法获得这些关系，我们也可以提醒自己信息匮乏的事实，人类是复杂的，任何关于另一方的单一叙事都必然会掩盖远多于它所阐明的东西。在最好的时候，有魅力的人可以让混乱的世界感觉更有序。他们可以为我们的日常生活注入目的和意义。他们让我们感觉良好，
and we want to be close to them. I was in New Orleans some months ago, and word got out that Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey were eating at a private room in a restaurant. Word leaked out, and soon the crowd started gathering. The intersection was soon swamped with hundreds of people. All they wanted, a glimpse of their heroes. It made me think about the connection between charisma and romantic love. When we fall deeply in love, the person we adore seems to walk on water. Every gesture they make is beautiful. Every word is a pearl. When you think about it, we relate to our lovers as if they were imbued with charisma. Their quirks, their habits, their sense of humor, we find every aspect of them to be fascinating and charming. So what happens when one of these
我们想靠近他们。几个月前我在新奥尔良，有消息传出泰勒·斯威夫特和特拉维斯·凯尔西正在一家餐厅的私人包间里吃饭。消息泄露了，很快人群就开始聚集。十字路口很快被数百人挤得水泄不通。他们想要的只是看一眼他们的偶像。这让我想到了魅力与浪漫爱情之间的联系。当我们坠入爱河时，我们崇拜的人似乎能凌波微步。他们做的每一个动作都是美丽的。说的每一句话都是珍珠。当你仔细想想，我们与爱人的关系就像他们被赋予了魅力一样。他们的怪癖、习惯、幽默感，我们发现他们的每一个方面都令人着迷和着迷。那么当这些……
relationships comes to an end? Breakups are devastating because they demand that we wrench ourselves from the orbit of someone we found irresistible. It becomes something like, oh, you're not entirely the person I thought you were. I thought that you would honor the relationship the way I hope to honor the relationship. When we come back, we dig deep into the psychology of breakups as we respond to listener questions about the end. of relationships. Stay with us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
关系结束时会发生什么？分手是毁灭性的，因为它们要求我们把自己从一个我们觉得不可抗拒的人的轨道上强行拉开。这变得有点像，哦，你并不完全是我以为的那个人。我以为你会像我希望尊重这段关系那样尊重这段关系。回来后，我们将深入探讨分手的心理学，并回答听众关于关系终结的问题。请继续收听。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are certain painful experiences almost all of us will have to go through. We'll have uncomfortable first days at a new school or a new job. We'll fight with your friends. We'll grapple with the grief of losing a parent. And unless we're very lucky, we'll break up with someone or have our heart broken by someone. someone we love. In movies and on TV, breakup scenes often make us laugh. It seems so obvious to us, the audience, that this relationship is doomed. But in real life, there often isn't much to laugh about when you're in the middle of a breakup. When you're the one sitting across the table from the person you love, hearing them say, I'm leaving you can be an agonizing experience.
这是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们几乎所有人都要经历某些痛苦的经历。我们会在新学校或新工作的第一天感到不自在。我们会和朋友吵架。我们会努力应对失去父母的悲伤。除非我们非常幸运，否则我们都会和某人分手，或者被我们爱的人伤透心。在电影和电视中，分手场景经常让我们发笑。对我们观众来说，这段关系注定要失败似乎太明显了。但在现实生活中，当你处于分手之中时，往往没什么可笑的。当你坐在你爱的人对面，听着他们说“我要离开你”时，这可能是一种痛苦的经历。
The period that follows the initial shock of a breakup can often bring its own distinct heartache. You're start to question everything. Did they really love you? What did you do wrong? Could you win them back? Was there someone else? How long will it take you for you to stop thinking about them? At the University of Windsor and Canada, Antonio Pasqua Leone studies how we process breakups and how we can make this particular type of loss less painful. Antonio joined us as part of our recent Love 2.0 series. If you missed that episode, it's the one in this podcast feed titled How to Move On. Today, we welcome Antonio back to respond to listeners' thoughts and questions in our popular segment,
分手最初冲击之后的那段时间往往会带来独特的伤痛。你开始质疑一切。他们真的爱你吗？你做错了什么？你能挽回他们吗？有别人吗？你需要多久才能停止想他们？在加拿大的温莎大学，安东尼奥·帕斯夸·莱昂内研究我们如何处理分手，以及我们如何能让这种特殊的损失不那么痛苦。安东尼奥作为我们最近“爱2.0”系列的一部分加入了我们。如果你错过了那一集，它就在这个播客源中，标题是“如何继续前行”。今天，我们欢迎安东尼奥回来，在我们的热门环节“回答你的问题”中回应听众的想法和问题。
your questions answered. Antonio Pasquale Leone, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shanker. Antonio, after we released our episode with you, we heard from listeners who shared how they had struggled or were continuing to struggle with really deep sorrow in the aftermath of a breakup. I'd like to start with this message we received from a listener. named Molly, she went through a breakup about 13 years ago, and it took her a long time to get over the
安东尼奥·帕斯夸·莱昂内，欢迎回到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。安东尼奥，在我们发布了关于你的那一集之后，我们收到了听众的来信，他们分享了他们在分手后如何挣扎，或者继续挣扎于深深的悲伤之中。我想从我们收到的一位名叫莫莉的听众的留言开始。她大约在13年前经历了一次分手，她花了很长时间才从……
loss of the relationship. Why is it that if I were dating this person and he died, I would be allowed and in fact even expected to continue loving him for the rest of my life. But because he is not dead, I am expected to get over it to stop loving him, to move on. What I don't understand is sort of what is the difference? I mean, isn't a breakup essentially a death? That relationship is dead. The person that we knew is dead to us now. Why are we supposed to approach breakups differently than
关系的损失中走出来。为什么如果我在和这个人约会，而他死了，我会被允许，甚至被期望在余生中继续爱他。但因为他没死，我就被期望“走出来”，停止爱他，继续前行。我不明白的是，区别在哪里？我的意思是，分手本质上不是一种死亡吗？那段关系死了。我们认识的那个人现在对我们来说已经死了。为什么我们被要求以不同于……
an even more permanent kind of loss? So Antonio, I think Molly is looking for permission to continue to grieve, well beyond the point that others think she should stop grieving. Is she right? I mean, I think it's an interesting question. I can hear the pain in Molly's voice and how she sort of has been sitting with this for 13 years, over a decade, right? And part of the problem, you know, let me just answer her question, which I think is the first part is our breakups the same or similar to somebody just dying. And I mean, they're both going to be very hard, but you break up because someone doesn't want to be in the relationship. Someone is unhappy and someone wants it to end. So there's a
一种更永久的损失的方式来对待分手？所以安东尼奥，我认为莫莉是在寻求继续悲伤的许可，远远超过了其他人认为她应该停止悲伤的时间点。她是正确的吗？我的意思是，我认为这是一个有趣的问题。我能听到莫莉声音里的痛苦，以及她是如何在13年，超过十年里一直纠结于此的，对吧？问题的一部分，你知道，让我先回答她的问题，我认为第一部分是：分手和某人去世是一样的或相似的吗？我的意思是，它们都会非常艰难，但你分手是因为有人不想维持这段关系。有人不快乐，有人想结束它。所以有一个……
difference in vision. And that has to be dealt with. It has to be accepted by the person who's being broken up with. In death, it's possible that both people are really happy. and then somebody dies. And so it just has to be accepted. You know, you might feel like the universe is unfair, but it's not a struggle between two people's visions of what we could do together. Right.
愿景上的差异。这必须得到处理。必须被那个被分手的人所接受。在死亡中，有可能两个人真的都很幸福，然后某人去世了。所以这只需要被接受。你知道，你可能会觉得宇宙是不公平的，但这并不是两个人对我们能一起做什么的愿景之间的斗争。对吧。
So when someone dies, we may grieve them, but we don't necessarily feel rejected by them. But in a breakup, the person who splits up with you is still walking around, still doing their thing, perhaps now with someone else. I can see in some ways how that can be more painful. Yeah, I mean, you have a disagreement, a difference in how you see things, right? There's the relationship has expired or turned sour or run its course.
所以当某人去世时，我们可能会为他们悲伤，但我们不一定会感到被他们拒绝。但在分手时，那个和你分手的人还在四处走动，还在做他们自己的事，也许现在和别人在一起。我可以在某种程度上看出这怎么会更痛苦。是的，我的意思是，你们有分歧，对事物的看法不同，对吧？关系已经过期、变质或走到了尽头。
You know, the other piece that Molly kind of points at or that comes to my mind is, it's been a long time, right? And of course, one's resources, emotional, cognitive, otherwise are trapped kind of stuck on this and there might be more life to live, right? It's important to end something so that one feels freed up to explore new possibilities. Antonio, a listener wrote in with a hypothesis about why things often get worse before they get better after a breakup. Carlos Alberto saw something online that said that after a relationship ends, people may experience a withdrawal of sorts from their ex-partner.
你知道，莫莉指出的或者我脑海中浮现的另一件事是，已经过去很长时间了，对吧？当然，一个人的资源，无论是情感上的、认知上的还是其他的，都被困在了这一点上，可能还有更多的生活要过，对吧？结束某件事很重要，这样一个人才会感到自由，去探索新的可能性。安东尼奥，一位听众提出了一个关于为什么分手后情况往往在好转之前先恶化的假设。卡洛斯·阿尔贝托在网上看到说，关系结束后，人们可能会经历一种与前伴侣的“戒断”。
Essentially, the post suggested that the struggle we feel after a breakup might be similar to the cravings of someone experiencing an addiction. Here's Carlos Alberto. And I feel that this view is very reductive of the relationship, and it doesn't really encompass all the complex things that are going around. But on the other hand, I do feel that it makes sense in a certain way. So my question is specifically if there is value in this understanding of breakups as recovering from addiction or if this is a rabbit hole that is not really worth exploring.
本质上，这篇文章暗示我们分手后感到的挣扎可能类似于经历成瘾的人的渴望。这是卡洛斯·阿尔贝托。我觉得这种观点对关系的描述过于简化，它并没有真正涵盖周围所有复杂的事情。但另一方面，我确实觉得它在某种程度上是有道理的。所以我的问题具体是，将分手理解为从成瘾中恢复是否有价值，还是这是一个不值得探索的死胡同。
What do you think, Antonio, is the comparison between breakup grief and addiction withdrawal on the money? You know, when you first introduced it, I thought, well, I don't know. And then the first thing Carlos said, I realized Carlos and I were on the same page. It is a bit reductionistic, right? You know, there are some things that are just very sort of functional in terms of getting over an addiction that might be similar, behaviorally, in terms of getting over a relationship. You're going to have to change your lifestyle. You're going to have to change who you hang out with. So there's some similarity there.
你觉得呢，安东尼奥，将分手悲伤与成瘾戒断进行比较准确吗？你知道，当你第一次介绍它时，我想，嗯，我不知道。然后卡洛斯说的第一件事，我意识到卡洛斯和我的想法是一致的。这确实有点简化论，对吧？你知道，在克服成瘾方面有一些非常实用的东西，在克服关系方面可能在行为上是相似的。你必须改变你的生活方式。你必须改变你和谁在一起。所以这方面有一些相似之处。
But I think the issue of relationships and grief become also more complicated. It is reductionists to think of it as just that. Because as Carlos was kind of hinting, there are other issues of personal meaning, of attachment, of identity. And, you know, there's no correlate there with respect to drug addiction. Antonio, a listener named Cliff reached out with a question about how to know when we might be stalled out versus taking time to recover from a breakup. Cliff and his wife got together when they were teenagers and they were married for 25 years. But eight years ago, Cliff's wife asked for a divorce. It threw him for a loop and he says he's still struggling to move on.
但我认为关系和悲伤的问题变得更加复杂。认为它仅仅是那样是简化论。因为正如卡洛斯所暗示的那样，还有个人意义、依恋、身份等其他问题。而且，你知道，在药物成瘾方面没有相关性。安东尼奥，一位名叫克里夫的听众提出了一个问题，关于如何知道我们是陷入了停滞，还是在花时间从分手后恢复。克里夫和他的妻子在十几岁时就在一起了，他们结婚了25年。但八年前，克里夫的妻子提出了离婚。这让他措手不及，他说他仍然在努力前行。
Here he is. I'm healthy, active and have a good career. Yet I feel unable to move forward emotionally. The idea of dating again in my 50s even after eight years still feels impossible. Being alone feels safer than risking being hurt or blindsided again. at the same time I recognize that this belief may be irrational. My question for Antonio is, how can I tell the difference between thoughts that are irrational and those that may simply reflect caution or self-protection? Is choosing to remain alone indefinitely, any irrational response
这是他。我很健康、活跃，事业有成。但我感到无法在情感上继续前行。即使在八年后，50多岁时再次约会的想法仍然感觉是不可能的。独处比冒着再次受伤或被突袭的风险感觉更安全。与此同时，我认识到这种信念可能是非理性的。我问安东尼奥的问题是，我该如何区分非理性的想法和那些可能仅仅反映谨慎或自我保护的想法？选择无限期地保持单身，是一个非理性的反应……
to my experience, or could it be a reasonable choice for where I am now? And how might someone in my position, even if I try dating, begin to trust the emotional roller coaster that can come from So Cliff raises a really interesting point, Antonio. It isn't always easy to tell where the line is between healthy self-protection and irrational fear. Do you have any advice for him? My heart goes out to him when one sort of speculates that it may be irrational that suggests that it's something that's crossed his mind. You know, but there's also no obligation to date other people. You don't have to. There's nothing wrong with. deciding, well, I'm fine on my own. That's okay, too. So really the question sort of becomes, what hurts more? What's missing in your life? Is something missing in your life? I mean, life is risky business. So, you know, we date somebody and they might not be interested in you,
对我的经历来说，还是对于我现在的处境来说，这可能是一个合理的选择？对于像我这样的人，即使我尝试约会，该如何开始信任可能随之而来的情感过山车？所以克里夫提出了一个非常有趣的点，安东尼奥。区分健康的自我保护和非理性的恐惧并不总是那么容易。你对他有什么建议吗？当一个人推测这可能是非理性的时候，我的心都碎了，这表明这是他脑海中闪过的东西。你知道，但也没有义务去和别人约会。你不必这样做。决定“我一个人很好”并没有什么错。那也可以。所以真正的问题变成了，什么更痛？你的生活中缺少了什么？你的生活中缺少了什么吗？我的意思是，生活是有风险的生意。所以，你知道，我们和某人约会，他们可能对你不感兴趣，
or you might be not so interested in them. And then there's that whole, I mean, it's a lot of work finding the right person. But, you know, we don't look for people because it's convenient. We look for people because we want to connect. And so I think Cliff, it might be useful to sort of consider to what extent am I depriving myself of possibilities, right? I knew somebody who once said, I broke up with so-and-so so that I would have to have. the possibility of falling in love again. You know, so what do you need, I guess, and what hurts the most? Because it costs you something to be so safe as well.
或者你可能对他们没那么感兴趣。然后还有那个，我的意思是，找到合适的人需要做很多工作。但是，你知道，我们寻找伴侣不是因为方便。我们寻找伴侣是因为我们想要连接。所以我认为克里夫，考虑一下我在多大程度上剥夺了自己的可能性可能是有用的，对吧？我认识一个人曾经说，我和某某分手是为了让我有再次坠入爱河的可能性。你知道，所以我猜你需要什么，什么最痛？因为保持如此安全也是有代价的。
Many of the most common questions we ask after a breakup are why questions. We want to understand why this rupture happened. We find ourselves pouring over our relationship, looking for clues. When we come back, we dig deeper into this process, and we'll talk with Antonio about how to know when it's time to start letting go. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Throughout our lives, we all will experience various kinds of rejections.
分手后我们问的最常见的问题很多是“为什么”的问题。我们想了解为什么会发生这种破裂。我们发现自己反复思考我们的关系，寻找线索。回来后，我们将深入探讨这个过程，并与安东尼奥讨论如何知道什么时候该开始放手。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们的一生中，我们都会经历各种各样的拒绝。
Maybe we'll be turned down for a part in the school play. Our dream university will say no to us. We'll toil over a job application only to receive a generic response saying, thanks but no thanks. But one of the worst forms of rejection is the end of a relationship. To have someone say, I know you, I loved you,
也许我们会因为学校戏剧中的一个角色而被拒绝。我们梦想的大学会对我们说不。我们辛苦准备一份工作申请，却只收到一封通用的回复，说“谢谢，但不用了”。但最糟糕的拒绝形式之一是关系的终结。让某人说，我认识你，我爱过你，
but I no longer want to be with you. Antonio Pascual Leone is a psychologist who studies the impact of relationships on our well-being and how we can navigate the emotions that engulf us after a breakup. Antonio, when you tell people about your research, they're sometimes skeptical about whether the emotions we experience after a breakup are generalizable, they assume that each person's response is unique.
但我不再想和你在一起了。安东尼奥·帕斯夸·莱昂内是一位心理学家，研究关系对我们幸福的影响，以及我们如何应对分手后淹没我们的情绪。安东尼奥，当你告诉人们你的研究时，他们有时会怀疑我们分手后经历的情绪是否具有普遍性，他们认为每个人的反应都是独特的。
Is it? Well, each person is unique. You know, in the details, in the way you experience it, and what it means to you, obviously, that's like a thumbprint. That's your unique experience. And at the same time, you know, is it unique? Isn't actually going to be an opinion question. this is an empirical question.
是这样吗？嗯，每个人都是独特的。你知道，在细节上，在你经历它的方式上，以及它对你意味着什么，显然，那就像指纹一样。那是你独特的经历。与此同时，你知道，它是独特的吗？这实际上不是一个观点问题，这是一个实证问题。
There are some common patterns that predict wellness outcomes. And, you know, that's probably because we're humans and humans have a similar parameters for their functioning. You know, you attend to certain. There's a lot of overlapping human needs. It's a funny puzzle, though, because if I were an astrophysicist, I would say, well, it's like this. and people would sort of nod and go, okay, I guess so. I can't see that far, so I'll take your word for it. But relationships and emotion, everybody, everybody has direct experience,
有一些共同的模式可以预测健康结果。而且，你知道，这可能是因为我们是人类，人类有相似的功能参数。你知道，你关注某些……有很多重叠的人类需求。不过，这是一个有趣的谜题，因为如果我是一位天体物理学家，我会说，嗯，它是这样的。人们会点头说，好吧，我想是这样。我看不那么远，所以我相信你的话。但关系和情感，每个人，每个人都有直接的经验，
which is kind of wonderful, but it also means that people hold up what we find against their personal belief system, the personal kind of experiences. Now, after a break up, many people find themselves turning things over and over in their minds, a process that it's known as rumination. Talk a moment about why we do this and why it can sometimes be a problem. Well, rumination is almost always a problem, right? I mean, it's tricky to know, am I ruminating or am I getting stuff done? Rumination is busy work, right?
这很棒，但也意味着人们会根据他们的个人信仰体系、个人经历来衡量我们的发现。现在，分手后，许多人发现自己在脑海中反复思考，这个过程被称为“反刍”。谈谈为什么我们这样做，以及为什么它有时会成为一个问题。嗯，反刍几乎总是一个问题，对吧？我的意思是，很难知道，我是在反刍还是在完成工作？反刍是忙碌的工作，对吧？
It's emotional. There are emotions there, right? You can think of three kinds of rumination. The anxious rumination is always worrying about the future and creating scenarios. What if this and what if that? When we talk about things like unfinished business or losses, relationship losses, you'll get more depressive rumination.
它是情感上的。那里有情绪，对吧？你可以想到三种反刍。焦虑的反刍总是担心未来并创造场景。如果这个怎么办，如果那个怎么办？当我们谈论未竟之事或损失、关系损失时，你会得到更多的抑郁性反刍。
Depressive rumination tends to be about the past. It's not about problem solving, but it's about if only I should, if only I had, you know, it's regrets, kind of replaying events of the past and if they had been a little bit different. Of course, there's an overlap between depressive and anxious rumination.
抑郁性反刍往往是关于过去的。它不是关于解决问题，而是关于“如果当初我……”、“如果我曾经……”，你知道，它是遗憾，有点重演过去的事件，如果它们稍微不同一点就好了。当然，抑郁性和焦虑性反刍之间有重叠。
The third kind I'll just mention to be complete here. I'm sure we could make up others. but when we're talking about relationship is angry ruminations. And these also are scenarios. They tend to be vengeful at the end, right, in certain kind of ways. If only I had said that clever thing, and I hope so-and-so gets their comeuppance. But notice these are all scenario-based. They tend to be a replaying of a scenario.
为了完整起见，我还要提到第三种。我相信我们可以编造其他的。但当我们谈论关系时，是愤怒的反刍。这些也是场景。它们在最后往往是报复性的，对吧，以某种方式。如果当初我说了那句聪明的话就好了，我希望某某得到报应。但请注意，这些都是基于场景的。它们往往是场景的重演。
It's the plot and characters being reworked. And it tends to be a very cognitive verbal loop. Keeps you really busy. So especially when it's anxious, you feel productive in some sort of way. And yet that verbal cognitive loop insulates you from sinking a bit deeper into what's really going on, which is the present, right? Issues of loss, issues of shame that can be very painful. You don't get caught up in those much more maladaptive emotions because you stay on these secondary, hopeless, helpless, rageful sort of things. We received a lot of listener questions about rumination. I'd like to share a couple of them with you.
这是被重写的剧情和角色。而且它往往是一个非常认知的语言循环。让你非常忙碌。所以尤其是当它焦虑时，你会在某种程度上感到富有成效。然而，那个语言认知循环使你与更深层地沉入正在发生的事情隔绝开来，那就是现在，对吧？损失的问题，羞耻的问题，这些可能非常痛苦。你不会陷入那些更适应不良的情绪中，因为你停留在这些次要的、绝望的、无助的、愤怒的事情上。我们收到了很多听众关于反刍的问题。我想和你分享几个。
The first is from a listener named Sophie. Sophie told us that she and her boyfriend broke up earlier this year because of something that she did. Here she is. I'm trying to piece together this version of me that loved him so much and then this. version of me that did what I did and hurt him, and the two aren't connecting, and it really scares me and freaks me out and makes me question whether or not I am a good person, a person who should be in romantic relationships. Is it possible to truly move on and heal from a breakup that was essentially your fault? So Sophie is stuck on the idea that perhaps she isn't the kind of partner or maybe even the kind of person that she thought she was. What can people do when they
第一个来自一位名叫苏菲的听众。苏菲告诉我们，她和男朋友今年早些时候分手了，因为她做的一件事。这是她。我正在试图拼凑这个曾经如此爱他的我，然后是这个做了我所做的事并伤害了他的我，两者无法连接，这真的让我害怕，让我抓狂，让我质疑我是否是一个好人，一个应该处于恋爱关系中的人。是否有可能真正走出来，从本质上是你自己造成的破裂中治愈？所以苏菲被困在一种想法中，即她可能不是她以为的那种伴侣，甚至可能不是她以为的那种人。当人们……
find themselves in this sort of ruminative cycle, Antonio? One thing Sophie's doing is, or at least in this excerpt, right, is thinking of herself in a relatively static way, right? It's like, I hurt somebody, I ended the relationship. So in life and in relationship, and in relationship, relationships, you get to reinvent yourself. You have choices now. You get to decide to do things differently. If you have regrets about the way you treated somebody, you can commit to not treating other people in that way. And I don't think you should sit around and wait until you're perfect before you're in a relationship because that's not really how it works. Nobody's got it all sorted out perfectly. And the truth is, you grow the most on the contact points, on the boundary
发现自己处于这种反刍循环中时，安东尼奥，人们能做什么？苏菲正在做的一件事，或者至少在这个片段中，对吧，是以一种相对静态的方式思考自己，对吧？就像，我伤害了某人，我结束了这段关系。所以在生活中，在关系中，在关系中，你有机会重塑自己。你现在有选择了。你决定以不同的方式做事。如果你对对待某人的方式感到遗憾，你可以承诺不再以那种方式对待其他人。我不认为你应该坐着等待，直到你完美了才进入一段关系，因为那不是它的运作方式。没有人能完美地解决所有问题。事实是，你在接触点上，在边界上成长最多。
line between you and someone else. You grow the fastest. It's hard to compromise. It's hard to negotiate. It's hard to have a sense of we, but that changes you. And so you'll become a different person by being in a different relationship. I would imagine that the rumination process is particularly common when a breakup is sudden and you don't know why the other person cut things off. A listener named Frida wrote in about her recent breakup. Her boyfriend ended things
在你和别人之间。你成长得最快。妥协很难。谈判很难。拥有“我们”的感觉很难，但这会改变你。所以你会通过处于一段不同的关系中而成为一个不同的人。我想象当分手很突然，你不知道对方为什么切断联系时，反刍过程特别常见。一位名叫弗里达的听众写信谈到了她最近的分手。她的男朋友突然结束了……
with her out of the blue. She writes, I really don't know exactly why he broke it off. I've asked to talk with him several times and he always makes excuses not to talk. Previous relationships have ended gradually or with a clear reason. I'm having a hard time moving on and still want to
和她的关系。她写道，我真的不知道他为什么要分手。我要求和他谈过几次，他总是找借口不谈。以前的关系要么是逐渐结束的，要么是有明确原因的。我很难走出来，仍然想……
talk with him about what happened. Any advice on how to move on? I'm wondering, Antonio, how can we find closure when a relationship ends and the person who has ended it won't give us any answers? Yeah, I think a lot of people get stuck there. Sometimes there's even ghosting or other sorts of very abrupt endings and the person's out there somewhere, but they're unresponsive. In the episode we did, something that we talked about was the idea that although the relationship was a shared project, me letting go and moving on after the relationship is not a shared project. We will not be doing that together, just like we don't break up together, meaning insincrony, right?
和他谈谈发生了什么。关于如何走出来有什么建议吗？我在想，安东尼奥，当一段关系结束，而结束它的人不给我们任何答案时，我们如何找到终结感？是的，我认为很多人被困在那里。有时甚至有“幽灵化”或其他非常突然的结束，那个人在外面某个地方，但他们没有回应。在我们做的那一集中，我们谈论的一件事是，虽然这段关系是一个共同的项目，但我放手并在关系结束后继续前行并不是一个共同的项目。我们不会一起做这件事，就像我们不是一起分手一样，意味着同步，对吧？
And henceforth, it's like, this is my own project. Obviously, reaching out, there's nothing wrong with that, trying to have a conversation, trying to get closure. Maybe there are things that you want to tell the person, maybe the things you want to ask. But you will make use of that in the way that's useful to you. And if they're unavailable or unwilling, then that is actually information. It becomes something like, oh, you're not entirely the person I thought you were. I thought that you would honor the relationship the way I hope to honor the relationship. So that's another loss in some ways.
此后，这就像，这是我自己的项目。显然，联系对方，这没什么错，试图进行对话，试图获得终结感。也许有些事情你想告诉那个人，也许有些事情你想问。但你会以对你有用的方式利用它。如果他们不可用或不愿意，那么这实际上就是信息。它变得有点像，哦，你并不完全是我以为的那个人。我以为你会像我希望尊重这段关系那样尊重这段关系。所以这在某种程度上是另一种损失。
But the relationship is yours to move on from, is what I'm trying to say. A listener named Jennifer wrote in about a situation where a relationship ends amicably, but the two people actually want to stay in contact with one another and try to remain friends. Here's Jennifer. I'm really struggling with how to do that because I'm just still working through my emotional baggage
但这段关系是你自己的，你可以从中走出来，这就是我想说的。一位名叫詹妮弗的听众写信谈到了一种情况，即一段关系友好地结束了，但两个人实际上想保持联系并试图保持朋友关系。这是詹妮弗。我真的在努力如何做到这一点，因为我还在处理我的情感包袱……
and the hurt that I feel. And at some point, I want to do it. Can it be done is my question. What do we need to do to make me? make that happen, each of us individually, or is it a giant mistake? I'm wondering, Antonio, have you seen any success stories of exes finding their way to becoming friends? Yeah. That's going to be a long road, though. It's not going to happen overnight. And I think it's wonderful when people do. You know, it depends how long ago the breakup has been.
以及我感到的伤害。在某个时候，我想这样做。我的问题是，这能做到吗？我们需要做什么才能让我……让它发生，我们每个人单独做，还是这是一个巨大的错误？我在想，安东尼奥，你见过前任成功成为朋友的案例吗？是的。那将是一条漫长的路。它不会在一夜之间发生。而且我认为当人们这样做时，这很棒。你知道，这取决于分手已经过去多久了。
and if that has been put to rest, right? But, you know, sometimes that's just a way of letting the other person down more easily. You know, one of the puzzles here and one of the reasons why there's going to have to be some time off, let's say. You know, are we wanting to be friends just because it follows on the heels of a very intimate and tight romantic relationship? Or are we wanting to be friends because if I didn't know you and I bumped to. into you at the library, we might become friends. One of the puzzles I just want to be really clear about it is the goal of the relationship, that that would be the new relationship, because you've kind of maxed out in terms of intimacy in the relationship with the person as you know them. You have
以及那是否已经平息了，对吧？但是，你知道，有时那只是让对方更容易接受的一种方式。你知道，这里的谜题之一，以及为什么必须有一段时间休息的原因之一，让我们这么说吧。你知道，我们想成为朋友仅仅是因为它紧随一段非常亲密和紧密的浪漫关系之后吗？还是我们想成为朋友是因为如果我不认识你，我在图书馆碰到了你，我们可能会成为朋友？我想明确的一个谜题是关系的终极目标，那将是新的关系，因为你已经在你所认识的人的关系中达到了亲密的极限。你有
been together, shared life, had dreams, made love. That's probably more intimate than most friendships. So now you're looking for friendship. So it's kind of to roll back the relationship. It's not going to be the same relationship. If you're able to become friends, it'll be getting to know the person in a whole different context. My parents is a funny example. My parents split up when I was 10. My father remarried.
在一起过，分享过生活，有过梦想，有过亲密关系。这可能比大多数友谊都要亲密。所以现在你在寻找友谊。这有点像是让关系倒退。它不会再是原来的那种关系了。如果你能成为朋友，那将是在一个全新的背景下重新认识对方。我父母就是一个有趣的例子。我10岁时父母分开了。我父亲再婚了。
And in some ways, I guess they kept in touch. Well, for many, I don't want to speak for them. Right. But it's like, well, they had kids. That becomes a shared project, right? So when I say redefine the relationship, it's the relationship becomes then about co-parenting. And that's important, right? We have different goals and there's a different end. Now my parents are quite elderly. And I remember, you know, we get together for holidays or birthdays. My father, my mother, my stepmother, my brothers. Everybody's at the same table. And it's great, right? And it's great. And it's, you know, we get together for holidays. you can tell these are now, these are friends, right? And there's a sense of community. So there's going to be a reinvention of the relationship for Jennifer, if that's what she wants. And it's not going to happen overnight, right?
在某些方面，我想他们保持了联系。嗯，对于很多人来说，我不想替他们代言。对。但就像，嗯，他们有孩子。那成了一个共同的项目，对吧？所以当我谈到重新定义关系时，是指这段关系变成了共同抚养孩子。这很重要，对吧？我们有不同的目标，也有不同的结局。现在我的父母年纪很大了。我记得，你知道，我们会在节日或生日聚在一起。我父亲、我母亲、我的继母、我的兄弟们。大家都在同一张桌子上。这很棒，对吧？这很棒。而且，你知道，我们会在节日聚在一起。你可以看出他们现在是朋友了，对吧？有一种社区感。所以，如果詹妮弗想要的话，她需要对这段关系进行重塑。而且这不会在一夜之间发生，对吧？
You're really going to have to give some time. You still have to end the relationship. When we go through a breakup, it can feel like we are saying more than just goodbye to our partner. We're also saying goodbye to the future we imagine together. The trips we would take, the life we would build. It's hard to imagine how to move forward, how to fill in all the gaps left behind. Up next, Antonio will answer your questions about how to find peace after a breakup
你真的需要给一些时间。你仍然必须结束这段关系。当我们经历分手时，感觉就像我们不仅仅是在对伴侣说再见。我们也在对我们共同想象的未来说再见。我们本会进行的旅行，我们本会建立的生活。很难想象如何继续前进，如何填补留下的所有空白。接下来，安东尼奥将回答你关于如何在分手后找到平静的问题。
and offer guidance on how to avoid a split in the first place. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Antonio Pasquale Leone is a psychologist at the University of Windsor and Canada. is the author of Principles of Emotion Change, What Works and When in Psychotherapy and Everyday Life. He joins us today for the latest installment in our series, Your Questions Answered. Antonio breakups are not always a surprise. Sometimes we know that a relationship isn't meant to be, and we pursue it anyway.
并就如何从一开始就避免分手提供指导。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱·莱昂是加拿大温莎大学的心理学家。他是《情绪改变的原则：心理治疗和日常生活中的有效方法与时机》一书的作者。他今天加入我们，参加我们系列节目“回答你的问题”的最新一期。安东尼奥，分手并不总是突如其来的。有时我们知道一段关系注定不会长久，但我们还是会继续追求。
This happened to one of our listeners named Celine. Her partner recently broke things off, and Celine is coming to realize that her own emotional issues might be playing a role in undermining her relationships. Here she is. Basically, long story short, in my scenario, I know why it didn't work out. There was a lot of communication issues and emotional disconnection and lack of effort because of it. What didn't help and a punch in the gut was the fact that I was dumped through a voice note. So what I'm currently struggling with is a lot of self-blame that I couldn't get myself to end it.
这发生在我们的一位听众塞琳身上。她的伴侣最近提出了分手，塞琳开始意识到她自己的情绪问题可能在破坏她的关系中起了一定作用。她在这里。简而言之，在我的情况下，我知道为什么它没有成功。有很多沟通问题、情感疏离，也因此缺乏努力。没能起到帮助作用且令人心痛的是，我竟然是通过语音留言被甩的。所以我目前正在挣扎的是，我有很多自责，因为我没能让自己主动结束这段关系。
And I guess my other issue is that I fall into loneliness and crave companionships before I get any work done on myself and basically start seeing other people before I know I'm ready. And I know myself enough that this is another struggle that is for sure to be expected. So it sounds like Celine is aware of what she needs to work on, Antonio, but finds it really difficult to follow through before loneliness compels. her to start a new relationship. What do you make of her dilemma? I think what Selina's saying is, I hope she feels like it's okay. It's like she's saying, I'm a work in progress, right? But we all are. I'd say to Selena, I am too. You know, so there's work to be done. And, you know, that doesn't
我想我的另一个问题是，我在还没对自己做任何心理建设之前，就陷入了孤独并渴望陪伴，基本上在还没准备好之前就开始见其他人了。我很了解自己，这绝对是另一个可以预见的挣扎。所以听起来塞琳很清楚她需要解决什么问题，安东尼奥，但发现很难在孤独感迫使她开始一段新关系之前坚持下去。你对她的困境有什么看法？我认为塞琳所说的是，我希望她觉得这没关系。这就像她在说，我是一个正在成长中的人，对吧？但我们都是。我会对塞琳说，我也是。你知道，所以还有很多工作要做。而且，你知道，那并不
mean one has to change relationships to improve oneself. One is often reinventing relationships as one changes who one is. But when she says about her own emotional issues, whatever they might be, she made reference to sort of a lack of effort. And that piqued me a little bit because I, you know, sometimes people say things like, well, you know, we'll see where it goes. When I hear somebody say, talk about lack of effort or we'll see where it goes, I cringe a little bit. I kind of go, well, I can make a good guess where it's going to go. Because the reality is that the rate of successive relationships is relatively poor, right? If we'd go by divorce rates are maybe close to 50%,
意味着一个人必须通过改变关系来提升自己。当一个人改变自己的本质时，往往也在重塑关系。但当她提到她自己的情绪问题时，无论那是什么，她提到了某种缺乏努力。这让我有点在意，因为我，你知道，有时人们会说一些话，比如，嗯，你知道，走着瞧吧。当我听到有人谈论缺乏努力或者“走着瞧吧”时，我会有点畏缩。我心想，好吧，我可以很好地猜到它会走向何方。因为现实是，后续关系的成功率相对较低，对吧？如果我们参考离婚率，可能接近50%，
depending on where you are. I'm just talking statistics. 50%. Those are bad odds. If you aren't sure that you want it to work, well, now you've given up your only leverage, right? Relationships work because you lean into them. And for that reason, one needs to sort of think about
取决于你在哪里。我只是在谈论统计数据。50%。这几率很差。如果你不确定你是否想让它成功，好吧，现在你已经放弃了你唯一的筹码，对吧？关系之所以有效，是因为你投入其中。因此，一个人需要思考一下
in what kinds of ways am I not leaning in? What gets in the way of me loving someone or allowing them to love me? So I think that's really key. Celine's question really highlighted how difficult it is to find a sense of ease when we've gone through a breakup. You've explored strategies that can help in these moments. One idea is to focus on identifying what you call unmet needs. Say more about this, Antonio.
我在哪些方面没有投入？是什么阻碍了我去爱某人，或者允许他们爱我？所以我认为这真的很关键。塞琳的问题确实突显了当我们经历分手后，找到一种轻松感是多么困难。你探索过可以在这些时刻提供帮助的策略。一个想法是专注于识别你所说的“未满足的需求”。多说一点，安东尼奥。
That's right, yeah. All emotion is about needs and negative emotions are about unmet needs. And you know, when you get to deeper feelings, I'll call them primary emotions, they're about not just highlighting something's wrong to you, but organizing you and orienting you to what you need, right? So emotion becomes procedural. I need to have a sense of camaraderie. I need to feel like understood by someone. I need a sense of playfulness. I need fun.
没错，是的。所有的情绪都与需求有关，而负面情绪则与未满足的需求有关。你知道，当你深入到更深层的情感时，我称之为“初级情绪”，它们不仅是为了向你强调出了什么问题，而且是为了组织你并引导你找到你所需要的东西，对吧？所以情绪变成了程序性的。我需要一种同志情谊。我需要感觉被某人理解。我需要一种俏皮感。我需要乐趣。
I need fun with somebody where we toss it back and forth. Those are existential and attachment-oriented needs, right? Often moving on is. about figuring out what's missing now, and once you're identifying it, you can kind of put it to rest, the relationship I mean, and you organize to start looking for that specific thing that you're missing. We received a number of messages from listeners who wanted to share their strategies for getting over a breakup. This one comes from a listener named Deb. At the age of 41, Deb went
我需要和某人一起享受乐趣，我们可以互相交流。这些是存在主义和依恋导向的需求，对吧？通常，继续前进是关于弄清楚现在缺少什么，一旦你确定了它，你就可以把那段关系放下，我的意思是，你开始组织起来寻找你所缺失的那种特定东西。我们收到了许多听众的来信，他们想分享自己克服分手的策略。这一条来自一位名叫黛布的听众。41岁时，黛布经历了
through a divorce. She struggled and felt like she'd never move on until about a year later, she decided to try something new. Here she is. I took out a yellow-lined writing pad and pen, and on every single line I wrote, thank you, and then I would fill in the blank for some way, shape, or form that my former husband had made my life better.
离婚。她挣扎着，觉得永远无法走出来，直到大约一年后，她决定尝试一些新的东西。她在这里。我拿出一本黄色横格记事本和一支笔，在每一行上我都写下“谢谢”，然后我会填空，写下我的前夫以某种方式、某种形式让我的生活变得更好的事情。
Five pages later, I had let out from my head and heart all those aspects of my former life with him that made a difference for my stories of the past, my impacts on the present, and possibilities for my future. That's what that letter meant to me. Outside of my new bedroom window, I made a sundial on the ground, and after crumbling up those heartfelt statements of gratitude, I burned them and imagine the resulting smoke moving through the air and to its intended recipient, my former husband.
五页纸之后，我从头脑和心中释放了前一段生活中所有那些对我的过去故事、对现在的我产生的影响以及对未来的可能性有意义的方面。这就是那封信对我意味着什么。在我新卧室的窗外，我在地上做了一个日晷，在揉碎了那些衷心的感谢声明后，我烧掉了它们，并想象产生的烟雾在空气中飘动，飘向它的预期接收者——我的前夫。
From that moment on, I could tell my story without pain or tears or anguish. It was fabulous. So there's abundant research that finds that gratitude is a powerful tool for many realms of our lives, Antonio. Is it possible that it can also help us with breakups? Absolutely. I think it's wonderful. It's very creative and it's very agentic and she runs with it, right? So part of it is very action or to do something.
从那一刻起，我可以讲述我的故事而没有痛苦、泪水或苦恼。这太棒了。所以有大量的研究发现，感恩是我们生活中许多领域的强大工具，安东尼奥。它是否也能帮助我们应对分手？绝对可以。我认为这很棒。它非常有创造力，而且非常有主观能动性，她坚持执行了，对吧？所以其中一部分是非常行动导向的，去做某事。
Nobody ruminates with a piece of paper the way Deb was talking about. I mean, at least not usually. So notice that one of the things here is she's committing to paper or to conversation with someone or to write. It's not just in your head going around, turning it around in circles. There's a sense of undertaking a task. The other piece that Deb mentions is ceremony, right? I mean, there's a ritual, the idea of, right? And I think I'm often saying to people, after you've done all the work, not before,
没有人会像黛布说的那样用一张纸来反刍。我的意思是，至少通常不会。所以请注意，这里的一件事是她将其付诸笔端，或者与某人交谈，或者写下来。它不仅仅是在你的脑海里转来转去，在圆圈里打转。这有一种承担任务的感觉。黛布提到的另一部分是仪式，对吧？我的意思是，有一种仪式，这个想法，对吧？而且我认为我经常对人们说，在你完成了所有的工作之后，而不是之前，
you can't do it at the beginning, but after you've done the work, you still have to decide that it's over. There's a decision point where you say, and I'm going to put this to rest. And that serves several functions. One, it creates a sense of closure. Notice the other person doesn't have to be here for this ceremony. It can be private.
你不能在开始时就做，但在你完成了工作之后，你仍然必须决定它已经结束了。有一个决定点，你说，我要把这件事放下。这有几个功能。第一，它创造了一种终结感。请注意，另一个人不必在这里参加这个仪式。它可以是私人的。
You do your own thing. It has to be done after you do the emotional work, of course. But it also becomes a reminder, a memento. There was that time, that moment in time and space where I let it go and walked into the rest of my life. life, which is what she describes, right? Then there's the piece about gratitude. In the original episode, we talked about a goodbye exercise where you might write down,
你做你自己的事。当然，这必须在你完成情感工作之后才能完成。但它也成为了一种提醒，一种纪念品。在那段时间，在那个时间和空间里，我放手了，走进了我余下的生活，这正是她所描述的，对吧？然后是关于感恩的部分。在最初的一集中，我们谈到了一个告别练习，你可以写下，
what are the good things you're saying goodbye to? What are the bad things you're saying goodbye to? You know, goodbye good rhythms. And what are the hopes and dreams, right? Because the reality is we had something together and it was of value. This next question is from a listener who is on the outside of a breakup looking in. Her name is Christine. I'm wondering how to help a friend who's been through a difficult breakup
你正在告别哪些好的事情？你正在告别哪些坏的事情？你知道，告别好的节奏。还有希望和梦想，对吧？因为现实是我们曾经在一起拥有过一些东西，而且它是有价值的。下一个问题来自一位处于分手局外观察者的听众。她的名字叫克里斯汀。我想知道如何帮助一个经历了艰难分手的朋友，
and seems to be stuck in a never-ending loop of rumination after a year or more and they just can't seem to move on. How can I be of help? What do you think, Antonio? Yeah, that was a good question, right? If you care about people and you see them suffering, you want to help them. It depends how long they've been stuck this sort of way. It depends how long the relationship is, right?
并且似乎在一年多后仍然陷入了无休止的反刍循环中，他们似乎无法走出来。我该如何提供帮助？你觉得呢，安东尼奥？是的，那是一个好问题，对吧？如果你关心别人，看到他们受苦，你会想帮助他们。这取决于他们陷入这种状态有多久了。这取决于关系的长度，对吧？
I think in some sense, if somebody were with a life partner and then the marriage ends or the relationship ends, a year after the breakup, they're still stuck with it and working through it. I wouldn't say that's outside of healthy, right? I mean, it takes time. And the longer the relationship, the more it's going to take time, right? You know, so it kind of depends on the context of what we're considering. But let's imagine it is kind of getting a little, it's taken a bit of a while. Maybe the relationship wasn't as significant in this person's life story, but obviously
我认为在某种意义上，如果某人与生活伴侣在一起，然后婚姻结束或关系结束，在分手一年后，他们仍然被困在其中并努力克服它。我不会说这超出了健康的范围，对吧？我的意思是，这需要时间。关系越长，需要的时间就越多，对吧？你知道，所以这在某种程度上取决于我们所考虑的背景。但让我们假设它确实有点，它花了一点时间。也许这段关系在那个人的生活故事中并不那么重要，但显然
important enough for them to feel broken over it. maybe the relationship was a year long and they're grieving for a year. This is starting to be a bit, well, yeah, that's a long time then, right? And if you're a friend or family member of somebody who's still grieving or seems stuck, I would say, give them company to fill the void. I would say help them figure out what's important to them. You know what I mean? Often at the end of a relationship, people don't really know what they're looking for.
对他们来说足够重要，以至于感到心碎。也许这段关系持续了一年，而他们悲伤了一年。这开始有点，嗯，是的，那时间太长了，对吧？如果你是仍然在悲伤或似乎被困住的人的朋友或家人，我会说，陪伴他们以填补空虚。我会说帮助他们弄清楚什么对他们来说是重要的。你知道我的意思吗？通常在一段关系结束时，人们并不真正知道他们在寻找什么。
So maybe give them some space to actually do that. The third thing would be, if people are really stuck in a hole, that's almost always from a first person perspective, right? Yeah, I feel sad when I think of myself and first person in this situation, but you can move the person to a third person perspective, kind of like somebody else looking in, right? And that would be you, of course. So then one starts talking about a life story, a life narrative.
所以也许给他们一些空间来真正做到这一点。第三件事是，如果人们真的被困在一个洞里，那几乎总是从第一人称的角度来看，对吧？是的，当我从第一人称的角度思考这种情况时，我会感到悲伤，但你可以将这个人转移到第三人称的角度，就像其他人从外面看一样，对吧？那当然就是你了。所以一个人开始谈论一个生活故事，一个生活叙事。
And you might have a story that's a sad story, but dot, dot, dot, where to from here? And the story's not yet finished. There's still life to live. So what do you want to do with that? And I think that is also important to help shake people up and lift their chin a bit to stare at the horizon. We focused most of this conversation on how to cope with feelings that come after a relationship ruptures. But I'd like to end with a listener question about how to support relationships that are not yet at the point of no return. A listener named Lou sent us a question along those lines.
你可能有一个悲伤的故事，但是，点点点，从这里开始去哪里？故事还没有结束。还有生活要过。那么你想用它做什么呢？我认为这对于帮助人们振作起来，抬起下巴去凝视地平线也很重要。我们把这次谈话的大部分重点放在了如何应对关系破裂后的感受上。但我最后想以一个听众的问题结束，关于如何支持那些还没有到“不归路”点的关系。一位名叫卢的听众给我们发了一个关于这方面的问题。
Lou says, I'd love to ask advice on how to break through the distance and silence that occurs when our romantic relationship feels like it's drifting apart. When both parties are feeling vulnerable and unsure of where they stand. what are some key questions we can ask our significant other to bring us back to honest communication? What do you think, Antonio? I think this is a lovely question from Lou. I have already said, if you're just waiting to see what happens, that's a coin toss, heads or tails, right? And is that what you want?
卢说，我很想请教关于如何打破当我们的浪漫关系感觉正在漂移时出现的距离和沉默的建议。当双方都感到脆弱且不确定自己的立场时，我们可以问伴侣哪些关键问题来让我们回到诚实的沟通？你觉得呢，安东尼奥？我认为这是卢提出的一个可爱的问题。我已经说过了，如果你只是等着看会发生什么，那就像抛硬币，正面还是反面，对吧？那是你想要的吗？
Because if that's what you want, then you'll get that, right? And yet, you know, you move through the procedures of life, the comings and goings, and we're busy with work and we're busy with stuff. Maybe you're busy with kids. You have projects. Relationship maintenance takes time. You've got to put time into it where there's a sense of we. That's a very strong predictor of good outcomes. So how do you do that?
因为如果那是你想要的，那么你就会得到那个，对吧？然而，你知道，你经历生活的程序，来来去去，我们忙于工作，忙于琐事。也许你忙于孩子。你有项目。关系维护需要时间。你必须投入时间，有一种“我们”的感觉。这是良好结果的一个非常强有力的预测指标。那么你该怎么做呢？
You look at your partner and you say, how are things? You make time for the relationship, you check in how they're doing. And sometimes the years roll by, and you actually have to reinvent the relationship. If you think of projects you've done, I don't know, I wrote a book, but people do other sorts of things, right? You renovate a house or you start a career or have children. And, you know, these things, a big project in life takes six to eight years, you know, from beginning to end. And, I mean, if you're having kids, it keeps going. But of course, the first six to eight years are really special and very hard.
你看着你的伴侣说，情况怎么样？你为这段关系腾出时间，你检查他们过得怎么样。有时岁月流逝，你实际上必须重塑这段关系。如果你想到你做过的项目，我不知道，我写过一本书，但人们做其他各种事情，对吧？你翻新房子，或者开始职业生涯，或者生孩子。而且，你知道，这些事情，生活中的一个大项目需要六到八年，你知道，从开始到结束。而且，我的意思是，如果你有孩子，它会一直持续下去。但当然，前六到八年真的很特别，也很艰难。
So, you know, if that's true for everything else, it's probably true for relationships, too. And if you don't reinvent the relationship every six to eight years, well, then it will probably expire. which is okay too. But if you wanted that relationship, you got to lean in, as I've been saying, and take the time to find a date night again. You don't have time for that. You have a date breakfast. Often one is kind of rediscovering. I find myself with my wife, we have kids. Our kids are like nine and ten now, and it's sort of like, oh, oh, that's who, oh, that's who you are. That's interesting. That's exciting. Be curious.
所以，你知道，如果这对其他一切都适用，那么它可能也适用于关系。如果你每六到八年不重塑一次关系，嗯，那么它可能就会过期。这也没关系。但如果你想要那段关系，你必须投入，正如我一直说的，并花时间再次找到约会之夜。你没有时间做那个。你有约会早餐。通常一个人是在重新发现。我发现我和我的妻子，我们有孩子。我们的孩子现在大约九十岁了，这有点像，哦，哦，原来你是这样的人。这很有趣。这很令人兴奋。保持好奇心。
That would be my advice. Be curious. Don't take it for granted. You know, I remember hearing someone say, if you don't make time for health, you are going to make time for illness. And I love that line because it suggests that being healthy is a proactive exercise.
那会是我的建议。保持好奇心。不要认为这是理所当然的。你知道，我记得听到有人说，如果你不为健康腾出时间，你最终将不得不为疾病腾出时间。我很喜欢这句话，因为它暗示了保持健康是一个主动的过程。
And as you're talking now, Antonio, I'm realizing the parallels here. If you don't make time for your relationship, you will make time for your breakup. It's very true, and it's very time-intensive if you have a breakup. Antonio Pascual Leone is a psychologist at the University of Windsor in Canada. He is the author of Principles of Emotion Change, What Works and When in Psychotherapy and Everyday Life. We also heard today from Molly Worthen.
安东尼奥，当你现在说话时，我意识到了这里的相似之处。如果你不为你的关系腾出时间，你就会为你的分手腾出时间。这是非常真实的，而且如果你分手了，它是非常耗时的。安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱·莱昂是加拿大温莎大学的心理学家。他是《情绪改变的原则：心理治疗和日常生活中的有效方法与时机》一书的作者。我们今天还听到了莫莉·沃森的发言。
She's a historian at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill and the author of Spellbound, how charisma shaped American history from the Puritans to Donald Trump. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
她是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的历史学家，也是《着迷：魅力如何塑造美国历史，从清教徒到唐纳德·特朗普》一书的作者。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung-hung hero today is Kelly Rudin. Kelly has worked for me for many years as my lecturing agent, she's fielded incoming calls and emails, and set up many speaking engagements. She's retiring, and I want to express my heartfelt gratitude for her many years of friendship and service. Kelly is a master gardener, and I expect she's going to get to spend many more hours in her beloved garden. Thank you again, Kelly. If you love Hidden Brain, please be an ambassador for us. Tell one or two friends about the show. Your word of mouth recommendations are one of the most
我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是凯利·鲁丁。凯利作为我的讲座代理人已经为我工作多年，她处理了来电和电子邮件，并安排了许多演讲活动。她要退休了，我想表达我对她多年友谊和服务的衷心感谢。凯利是一位园艺大师，我希望她能花更多时间在她心爱的花园里。再次感谢你，凯利。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请成为我们的形象大使。告诉一两个朋友这个节目。你的口碑推荐是连接更多人与我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探索的想法和研究的最
powerful ways to connect more people with the ideas and research we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
强大的方式之一。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。